Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur na neunundsechzigsten Ausgabe von UKW.
Und ja da sind wir wieder, es ist Freitag und das heißt Corona Wickly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Da hatten wir wieder eine ereignisreiche, ereignislose Woche würde ich mal sagen wo wieder ganz viel nicht passiert ist.
So ein bisschen mein Eindruck, weiß nicht, wie es bei dir war.
Ja, ja.
Ja, wir hatten uns ja äh vorgenommen, heute nicht zu sehr in äh Klagen, in ins Beklagen äh der Gesamtsituation
ja da nicht allzu viel Zeit äh mit äh zu äh verwenden, aber,
Ja ich mein es sieht so aus als hätten wir echt viel Zeit irgendwie in dieser Pandimie. Es scheint alles nicht so dann doch nicht so ernst zu sein. So hat man das Gefühl ich mein,
Ja und dann natürlich auch gesagt, was da jetzt an.
Ergebnissen bei rausgekommen ist, was jetzt äh diese Notbremse angeht. Ja, man hat.
Eindruck, es gi
gar keine Betriebsbremsen mehr für die Pandimie, so diese Notbremse äh und die wird dann auch von einigen nicht gezogen oder einige sind unwillig überhaupt die Notbremse zu ziehen, ja. Äh so, deswegen ja.
Hat man das Gefühl, so es geht halt auch vielleicht nicht ungebremst,
aber äh eben zu schwach gebremst äh immer noch nach oben. Und äh ja, plus natürlich ich meine.
Die Maßnahmen an sich sind halt auch ein schlechter Witz. Also irgendwas bei Institenz zweihundert festzuschreiben oder selbst bei hundert, wo die fünfzig schon so hoch waren und uns fünfunddreißig versprochen wurden, so das
äh ist halt äh einfach ähm ja,
zu sagen, wir wir lassen die Schulen bis Instit zweihundert auf, beziehungsweise, nein, wird ja betonen, nein, es ist ja nur eine Notbremse. Nichts hinder,
ein Land daran, jetzt auch früher schon die Schulen zuzumachen, aber so,
aber bis zweihundert kann man dann halt trotzdem gehen und zweihundert, das bedeutet einfach ähm ja,
eine, ich nenn's mal hochinstitenz Politik, äh, die da gefahren wird, die halt äh im Jahr Leid und Leben.
Kostet, also Leid verursacht und Leben kostet und auch Geld natürlich und ja das ist nichts anderes als eine Kapitulation. So,
sehe ich das. Ich meine, dann haben wir und jetzt sagen, okay, wenigstens ist es das, aber
Frage ist, reicht es eigentlich? Ich meine, eigentlich müsste es jetzt mit Schulen, also wenn Schulen und Kitas zu sind, äh sollte das eigentlich ausreichen, aber ja, nach wie vor eben Unternehmen.
Ähm ähm ja sind,
relativ wenig Einschränkungen unterworfen. Das ist, dafür ist unser Privatleben jetzt ziemlich äh zugenagelt jetzt auch noch mit ja, nächtlichen
Ausgangssperren äh die demnächst drohen und äh ja.
Vielen Einschränkungen, genau. Bevor wir da zu sehr äh ins Rahmen äh kommen.
Legen wir doch gleich mal los mit mit Feedback, weil das passt jetzt gerade eigentlich ganz gut dazu äh in den Kommentaren äh hat uns was soll's geschrieben. Vielen Dank für eure
informativen Folgen, dennoch finde ich, dass ihr zu sehr auf den Konzern äh rumhaut. Mein privates Umfeld arbeitet bei solchen. Diese befinden sich ausnahmslos seit einem Jahr im Homeoffice. Das Problem
mittelständischen Unternehmen ist, dass die Kollegen kein Homeoffice wollen. Und natürlich ist es meinem Arbeitgeber lieber, wenn alle ins Büro kommen. Es ist mithin
eine Mischung aus Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer und auch jetzt wird sich bei den Schnelltest von der Chefetage immer darauf bezogen, dass wir ja nicht müssen.
Ist zum Haare raufen. Ja,
die Wirtschaft, also hauen wir zu sehr auf den Konzern rum rum, also ich denke, was man ein bisschen differenzieren muss, ist so Wirtschaft, das ist äh relativ,
weiter Begriff
Wirtschaft ist ja eigentlich fast alles und äh Konzerne finde ich jetzt auch keine besonders gute Umschreibung. Ich habe so den Eindruck, es ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen die Industrie,
die eigentlich überhaupt nicht bereit ist, hier in irgendeiner Form was aufzugeben und bei den mittelständischen Unternehmen oder bei den mittleren Unternehmen habe ich
alles mögliche gesehen, ne? Also solche, die halt wirklich
hat man auch hier den den Bericht von von jemanden auf Clubhaus so, ja wir sind großes Unternehmen und gleich im Februar haben wir eine Taskforce gegründet und zwei Drittel war im Home Office und
so ist das irgendwie auch immer noch und es gibt irgendwie wöchentliche Updates und die Chefs reden irgendwie mit den Betriebsärzten und informieren alle. Das sind so so die positiven Beispiele. Aber es gibt halt auch eine ganze Menge negative Beispiele und auch aus dem Kommentar kann man halt einfach raus
äh lesen. Wenn's halt keine klare Ansage gibt und alles so auf Freiwilligkeit basiert, dann,
kocht da einfach jeder sein eigenes Süppchen mit dem Ergebnis, dass man äh insgesamt nicht weiterkommt.
Ja plus das äh gut,
in der Anfangszeit, also je nach je nachdem auch, ob dann ein Unternehmen in einer Hochinstitanzregion ist oder nicht. Äh so hat es dann eben auch Wettbewerbs
Nachteile möglicherweise
dadurch wenn es halt mehr tut oder zu viel tut, sag ich mal, wobei das dann im Endeffekt sich dann wieder bei hohen Institzen auszahlt, dass nicht so viele Mitarbeiter,
ausfallen, aber
unter dem Strich äh scheinen Mitarbeiter dann doch irgendwie eher auch ein bisschen manchmal als was offenbar Austauschbares oder ähm ja zumindest verzichtbares, zeitweise ähm,
gesehen zu werden und äh ja äh wir haben glaube ich immer betont, dass es da sehr, sehr große Unterschiede gib,
aber,
das Problem ist unterm Strich reicht's halt nicht. So, das kann man halt nicht wegreden, da kann sich halt jeder dann sagen, ja, wir machen aber, wir machen aber, aber es reicht halt nicht.
Offensichtlich machen halt dann eben nicht genug Leute genug in der Wirtschaft und es sieht halt ganz so aus, als wenn das eben
äh ja nicht die gesamte Wirtschaft ist, sondern bestimmte Teile und äh gerade eben vor allem aus bestimmten Industriebereichen hat man halt eben auch mitbekommen.
Wieder massiv Einfluss ausgeübt wird aus die Politik und das sind halt politisch sehr einflussreiche Lobbyorganisationen und wenn man.
Deren Stellungnahmen liest, dann ist es äh ja äh einfach äh klar, die Schulen sollen aufbleiben, hören, damit die Leute in Ruhe arbeiten können.
Und die Kitas äh natürlich und ansonsten ja äh lehnt man halt äh alles ab, was irgendwie ähm ja Geld kosten würde oder.
Zeit oder unangenehm ist. So sieht's äh aus. Ich meine.
Bei der bei der Testpflicht jetzt, was war das für ein gezählter, so, ich meine, nicht, das ist allzu viel nützen würde, weil das sowieso nicht vernünftig implementiert werden wird.
Aber äh ja es ist halt symptomatisch.
Und wie gesagt äh es zählen halt nur Ergebnisse und die Ergebnisse sind nicht da. Also.
Und äh und wir haben eben, wenn man mal sagen die in den äh Altersgruppen.
Halt vor allem berufstätig sind, so finden zwei Drittel des Infektionsgeschehens statt, ja? Das heißt.
Ähm klar passiert auch was im privaten Bereich, aber wenn man jetzt nie sagen, zwei Drittel sind nur äh nur Wirtschaft, aber äh ja.
Wenn man die ausklammert, dann kann man halt die Schulen nicht aufhalten. Das ist so, ich sag mal, dass das Problem ja.
Aber ja, wir wollten ja nicht so lange äh lamentieren.
Aber das bringt uns letzten Endes zur Bestandsaufnahme, nämlich den Zahlen der Woche.
Und während wir letzte Woche noch so ein bisschen die Ausläufer der Osterfeiertage gesehen haben und die Zahlen ja teilweise zurückgingen,
uns aber nicht so sicher waren, ob das irgendwie äh Substanz ähm hatte, also teilweise hatte es Substanz teilweise, war man sich nicht so sicher, wie viel Substanz es hatte.
Mittlerweile die Zahlen doch sich wieder ganz anders am Strecken und alles geht hoch, oder?
Ja, also sind ja schon längst äh deutlich über vor Osterniveau, also,
mit äh Jahnherr Institanz von hunderteinundsiebzig aktuell
in Deutschland und einem sieben Tage Erwert bei ja von eins Komma zwo zwo das
ist schon mal eine Menge und ja mein Loch hat sich das nicht ganz eingerüttelt, würde ich sagen, diese Phasenverschiebung, die durch,
Ostern äh passiert ist und äh im Augenblick.
Es ja auch ja rechts und links hagelt es in verschiedenen Bereichen dann schon Maßnahmen und Verschärfungen.
Sodass wir hoffentlich auch da noch eine zusätzlich dämpfende Wirkung.
Kriegen, aber ja was halt noch aussteht ist äh jetzt.
Die Auswirkung der Schulöffnungen, die wohl kommen werden, so wie es aussieht in.
Vielen Bundesländern und äh insofern erwarte ich jetzt, dass es vielleicht in den ja nächsten Tagen nochmal übers Wochenende ist, ja
Erfahrungsgemäß dann bis Montag und so äh dann,
wieder niedrige Zahlen bis Dienstag, aber wahrscheinlich ja geht es dann spätestens äh in der.
Nächsten Woche äh dann noch richtig los, wenn halt die Schulen offen sind und das kann dann ganz schnell gehen. Das kann dann ganz schnell gehen und äh ja.
Die Schulen eigentlich auch gleich wieder zu, weil zweihundert äh steht eigentlich vor der Tür und das ist eigentlich vollkommen absurd, jetzt nochmal äh überhaupt nochmal zu öffnen, wenn man sowieso weiß, dass man kurz vor zweihundert ist.
Um Sander einfach nochmal schlimmer zu machen, um's dann nochmal äh weiter rauszuzögern. Man hat einfach wirklich nicht mehr den Eindruck, dass auch nur irgendjemand noch irgendwas.
Checkt.
Ja ähm.
Die Zahl der Todesfälle hat halt auch wieder angezogen so ähm.
Seit.
Anfang April war sie auf eigentlich auf einem niedrigsten Stand beziehungsweise in der ersten Aprilwoche und äh ja jetzt so seit eigentlich,
zwei Wochen äh geht's da leider wieder aufwärts und ähm was vielleicht.
Unbegreiflich ist oder.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so einleuchtet ist, dass sich die Institzen in der Altersgruppe.
So achtzig Plus, wo man ja denken würde, da müssten jetzt eigentlich mal langsam alle durchgeimpft sein, oder?
Also auch in der Altersgruppe achtzig Plus gehen die Institzen wieder hoch. Zwar glücklicherweise jetzt auf niedrigem Niveau so.
Das ist jetzt auch gleichzeitig die neweste Insidenz.
Achtundsiebzig grade in Deutschland auf hunderttausend bei bei achtzig plus aber bei ja sich,
sechzig bis neunundsiebzig sehen wir halt noch höhere Anstiege und da liegt die Insedenz schon bei hundert und das ist halt eine Altersgruppe, die eben auch ja,
Größenordnungsmäßig ein Viertel bis ein Drittel äh so viele ähm Todesfälle hat äh pro.
Infektion, also das fällt halt auch nennenswert ins Gewicht und.
Ja und Schulen sind deutschlandweit äh oder ich sage mal äh Kinder im Alter von fünf bis vierzehn Jahren haben jetzt deutschlandweit eine Instituz von zweihundert.
Gerade. Und die höchste Insidenz ähm liegt in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig, die sind jetzt da sind jetzt zweihundertzweiundfünfzig von hunderttausend deutschlandweit infiziert.
Das heißt, die Schulen sollen zumachen, wenn die Institenz bei zweihundert ist. Und sie ist eigentlich bei zweihundert, bei den Schülern.
Bei den Schülern, ja.
Ja, aber nur weil's noch andere gibt, die schon geimpft sind, die aber mit diesen Schulen überhaupt nichts zu tun haben, bleibt mir halt noch offen.
So kann man sagen und ähm.
Die Kitas geht im Moment äh also null bis vier äh liegen deutschlandweit bei äh hundertvierundfünfzig äh Institanz, aber.
Und da lohnt es sich mal ähm in unsere Hochinzedenz.
Landkreise hineinzuschauen, zum Beispiel den Landkreis Greiz. Ähm ja.
Und.
Was wir da in Greiz dann sehen können, wo die Institanz ja jetzt äh auch im Schnitt so im
in der fünfhunderter äh Gegend liegt, aber das ist gar nicht so sehr das Spektakuläre, sondern das spektakuläre dort
ist es Mitte März.
Also begonnen hat es eigentlich Anfang März in der Altersgruppe null bis vier äh sind die Institzen dann bis zum ja siebzehnten dritten auf tausendsechshundert.
Angestiegen von hunderttausend, ja? Bei den bei den Kleinkindern, also da ist definitiv äh.
Was passiert und gleichzeitig bei den Schulen im selben Zeitraum äh unter den Fünf- bis Vierzehnjährigen eine Institz von über tausend.
Und eine Woche später ging dann dort bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen in Greiz die Institanz über tausend.
So und ähm dann kamen die fünfunddreißig bis,
neunundfünfzigjährigen nochmal ein bisschen hinterher, wo es dann bis neunhundert hochging, ja. Also ähm dass wenn man sich fragt, äh so wie,
wie schafft man das so auf solche Rekordinzidenzen zu kommen? Wie ja.
Oder Hof, äh, dann, äh, ja, kann man nur sagen, ja. Macht halt Schulen und.
Auf und äh ja und weiß nicht, was die da sonst noch dazu gegeben haben, aber
Ja, das ist schon Rekordverdichtung definitiv. Ja und wenn wir dann.
Vielleicht nochmal nach Hof gucken ähm ja in Hof waren's dann halt.
Die Schulen aber zu einem anderen, also gab's halt zwei irgendwie krasse äh Wellen, die auch von dort aber hauptsächlich den Schulen oder den fünfzehn bis Vierzehnjährigen ausgingen. Da ging's dann
Anfang März so von von Ende Februar bis Anfang März, innerhalb
einer Woche ging dann die Institzen bei den fünf bis.
Vierzehnjährigen von irgendwie hundertzwanzig auf sechshundertfünfzig hoch, ja? Und im selben Zeitraum, die bei den.
Bei den Kindern null bis null bis vier von
fünfzig auf sechshundertfünfzig, ja? In in einer Woche Bang. Ähm so kann das halt gehen, ja und dann äh ging äh
gingen die achtzig plus äh gleich hinterher so, wo auch immer, auch von, weiß nicht, von dreißig auf sechshundert Bänen, auch in fünf Tagen
sechs Tagen oder so, ja und ähm dann war Mitte März,
gingen die Zahlen dann erstmal ein bisschen runter so in den Dreihunderter Bereich und dann äh sind,
wieder die die Schulen und dann ging's halt erst bei den Fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen über achthundert rauf
und aktuell
Also in der letzten Woche haben in Hof äh einfach wieder die null bis vierjährigen so den den Vogel abgeschossen mit Institzen über neunhundert.
Und ähm ja und im Moment dort die niedrigste Institut.
Ähm ja sechzig bis neunundsiebzig. Die sind dort auf zweihundertfünfzehn runter aber die.
Ja das ist halt sehr
unschön, dass halt bei den acht über achtzig Jährigen dort jetzt eine Institanz von sechshundertsiebenundvierzig Grade herrscht, so, das heißt, äh da.
Wird halt ja von denen äh die da heute erkrankt sind kann man sagen wird.
Ja ungefähr ein Fünftel wird mit äh also in der Altersgruppe so wird sterben.
Ja.
Das ist äh und das geht halt gerade jeden Tag so weiter. Aber gut ähm so sieht's, so sieht's aus. Ähm.
Ja, zu den Testzahlen noch, weil die sind ja auch immer ein bisschen äh wichtig, um zu bewerten. Ähm.
Ob es da irgendwelche ja Änderungen gegeben hat beim Testen, die dann die Zahlen zu hoch oder zu niedrig erscheinen lassen, aber das ist nicht der Fall. Also in der vierzehnten Kalenderwoche ist.
Die Zahl der Tests minimal zurückgegangen. Ähm so um eins Komma drei Prozent auf jetzt eins Komma eins fünf.
Millionen aktuell und die positiven Rate ist auf zwölf Komma null vier Prozent jetzt angestiegen.
Das kann man vielleicht zu den Tests sagen, also sofern ja keine Änderungen im Testregime.
Genau, die positive Quote ist ja meine meine Lieblingslinie eigentlich, weil die so am einfachsten zu verstehen ist bisher hat,
die positiven Quote immer ganz hervorragend das Geschehen nachgezeichnet und wenn man äh das dann eben halt weiterhin als gültig ansieht, dann kann man einfach sagen
dritte Welle geht voran, ja? Also wir sind da fleißig noch am Klettern und bisher weist relativ wenig darauf hin,
nennenswert Schritte zurückmachen.
Eine Sache habe ich noch gemacht in der letzten Woche, die mich auch sehr lange interessiert hat
Pandemie läuft ja jetzt schon seit über zwölf Monaten und äh wir haben jetzt so Jahreszeitlich fast zwei Monate überlappende Pandemiedaten, das heißt man kann den Grafen,
diesem Jahr und den vom letzten Jahr einfach mal verschoben übereinander liegen und sich dann angucken, wo wir.
Jetzt stehen und wo wir um dieselbe Zeit ähm vor zwölf Monaten,
im April standen und äh der Vergleich sieht nicht gut aus. So vor zwölf Monaten genau um diese Zeit waren wir.
Bei ja ungefähr einer Institanz von fünfundzwanzig auf hunderttausend und.
Die Zahlen waren noch äh rapide im Fall. Wir hatten R-Werte um die null Komma acht zu der Zeit. Ja.
Und jetzt sieht es so aus, dass wir eben bei hundertfünfundsiebzig.
Liegen und auch noch der R-Wert bei über eins Komma zwei,
also es geht in die falsche Richtung und wir sind
ja im Prinzip drei Mal so hoch mit der Inzidenz. Was halt bedeutet das nicht zu erwarten ist, dass wir so wie im letzten Jahr,
lockern können und was zu befürchten lässt, dass eben ja sich das Ganze noch länger ins Frühjahr und bis in den Sommer hin äh zieht,
auf jeden Fall und eine Sache habe ich mir auch noch angeschaut, nämlich.
Wie viel größer eigentlich äh damals die Dunkelzifferquote war und äh ja ich bin auf etwa eins Komma sieben fünf gestoßen
das heißt, dass die Instit.
In der Spitze damals vor einem Jahr wahrscheinlich eher so zwischen fünfundachtzig und neunzig gelegen haben dürfte, so als Vergleichswert für die Spitze der.
Ersten Welle zur aktuellen Institz und ja.
Das ist alles nicht schön und verheißt nichts Gutes.
Auf jeden Fall ist dieser Mythos Saisonalität es einfach nicht zu halten. Also da ist irgendwie nichts dran.
Sieht sie, naja nix. Also sie kommt uns natürlich entgegen, sie wird uns helfen, aber es ist nicht die einzige und nicht mal die.
Wichtigste Einflussgröße jetzt gerade auf den RWE und die Entwicklung jetzt zeigt halt auch einfach, dass.
Wir damals durch einen Lokdown die Zahlen runtergebracht haben und nicht das Frühjahr. Ganz einfach.
Gut, so viel zum Zahlen äh Werk der Insidenzen.
Schauen wir doch mal äh zum auf das Zahlenwerk der Impfung. Da gab's ja dann ausnahmsweise mal ein paar ganz gute ähm Meldungen.
Soll's ja auch geben.
Sprich, das Impf-Tash-Board berichtet, dass äh in der letzten Woche ein Spitzenwert erreicht wurde, also es gab einen absoluten Rekord ähm Impftag.
Das war der Mittwoch, der vierzehnte vierte, da sind dann mal siebenhundertachtundfünfzigtausend,
Leute geimpft worden. Das ist schon ganz ordentliche Zahl, wenn man das jeden Tag hätten. Dann dann wäre alles ähm auf einem ganz guten Weg. Natürlich ist es nicht so, ne? Also gestern sind wir dann schon knapp unter siebenhunderttausend gelandet und
Tage davor fünfhunderttausend, aber wir haben jetzt schon erheblich mehr Impfungen gesehen in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Als in den es wird spannend sein zu sehen äh ob das gehalten werden kann, weil das natürlich primär von den Impfstofflieferungen abhängt, wenn man sich die anschaut, stellt man fest,
dass zum Beispiel in der letzten Woche ausschließlich Björn Tech geliefert wurde.
Weder moderner, noch von Astra Senika kam irgendwas dazu, trotzdem war das aber so ein signifikanter.
Zuwachs, dass es Impftempo gehalten werden konnte, fragt man sich natürlich jetzt, okay, wo kommt das her? Ganz klar, Hausärzte haben geimpft und Hausärzte haben auch relativ viel Astrasenika bereitgestellt bekommen, was offensichtlich noch,
unverbraucht rumlag.
Sprich kann sehr gut sein, dass diese Effekte, die wir sehen, einfach so ein, so ein Nachholeffekt ist, dass jetzt hier die Bestände quasi leer gemacht äh wurden und gerade weil's gerade ein bisschen hakbar Astra Senika dieser Speed so nicht gehalten werden kann.
Also in Berlin gibt's ja zum Beispiel gar kein Impfzentrum mehr, was Astra Sinica verimpft, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe oder zumindest jetzt eins geschlossen worden und ich glaube, das war auch das Einzige, oder?
Tegel ist das Astra Senika und das ist für ein paar Tage war das zumindest geschlossen, aber nicht.
Nee, ich, ich habe jetzt gelesen, dass es endgültig dicht gemacht wird, weil äh es.
Halt nur an Übersechzigjährige verimpft wird oder und es nicht sich dort nicht genug über Sechzigjährige gemeldet haben oder so, ne?
Also zumindest ist es noch mit mit Öffnungszeiten vermerkt auf der äh Webseite, also.
Ali, da ist äh Biontech, die sind auf Björn Tech umgestiegen.
Also der ganze Astra Senika-Impfstoff, der gibt quasi zu den Hausärzten und die Impfzentren kümmern sich ja äh primär noch um alte Leute und.
Machen das wohl so. Also das ändert sich am laufenden Meter. Also diese ganze Impfstofflogistik ist natürlich schwierig geworden
durch verschiedene Faktoren. Erstmal natürlich das Ganze hin und her rund um Astra Sinica, dann war's mal gesperrt, dann nicht, in erst war's nur für die Jüngeren, dann war's nur für die Älteren. Da sind wir jetzt im Prinzip auch immer noch und das hat natürlich zu für sehr viel Verwirrung
Verunsicherung natürlich auch gesorgt, das heißt ähm sowohl die Impfzentren als auch die Hausärzte haben durchaus Probleme, Astra Sinica an äh Mann und Frau zu bekommen
wie sich das entwickeln wird, keine Ahnung, werden wir sehen. Auf jeden Fall die Kernaussage ist die, wir haben jetzt zwei Wochen gute Zahlen gehabt.
Gibt noch keine Garantie dafür, dass sich das hält und das wird eben vor allem davon abhängen, wie so die Impfstofflieferungen laufen werden.
Insgesamt haben wir jetzt zwanzig Millionen über zwanzig Millionen Dosen ähm verimpft.
Offiziell sind das achtzehn Komma fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung, die zumindest eine Erstimpfung bekommen haben, sechs Komma vier Prozent.
Haben schon die zweite. Die beiden Zahlen werden jetzt künftig noch weiter auseinanderlaufen, weil ähm jetzt.
Ähm diese der Abstand zwischen Erstimpfung und Zweitimpfung weiter auseinander geht. Also wir haben.
Bisher ja das ja so gehabt, dass Bars Rasilika drei Monate genommen wurde und bei Bion Tech waren's drei Wochen und letzterer wird jetzt auf das Maximum ausgefahren, auf sechs Wochen.
Das heißt, die Zweitimpfungen werden jetzt alle sehr viel später stattfinden.
Das ist wohl jetzt auch schon seit einer Woche so Praxis und teilweise wurden auch äh existierende Termine nach hinten verlegt und ich finde, das macht auch durchaus Sinn.
Möglichst viele erstmal mit einer Erstimpfung zu versorgen, damit einfach schon mal dieser Grundschutz da ist, weil ja auch alle Studien relativ klar sagen, Erstimpfung bringt schon so richtig viel.
Und äh die Zweitimpfung ist sinnvoll und so ist es ja auch alles geprüft und abgenommen worden, aber es gib,
nicht unbedingt große Eile, das jetzt sofort nach drei Wochen machen zu müssen und deswegen wird also diese Kurve noch weiter auseinandergehen, beziehungsweise wird es eben sich positiv auswirken auf die Zahl der erstgeimpften, sodass wir da relativ bald,
zwanzig brozent durchmarschieren können.
Ja, aber ja, EPD-Biologisch äh wirkt sich das Ganze natürlich nur in den jetzt bei achtzig plus
und wie wir gesehen haben, reicht es selbst da noch nicht, also selbst bei weiß nicht, es ist halt
leider auch unklar, wie viel denn jetzt der Überachtzigjährigen eigentlich wirklich eine Impfung bekommen haben und wie viele davon vollständig geschützt sind, äh hast du da Zahlen.
Ich habe jetzt nichts weiter gefunden. Wir hatten ja letzte Mal, dass er beim RKI rausgepopelt. Ich habe jetzt nicht nochmal geschaut, aber letztes Mal war das ja auch unvollständig, dass nur neun von den sechzehn Bundesländern da die Zahl überhaupt so gemeldet haben
ob sie's nicht nur nicht gemeldet haben oder am Ende nicht wissen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall liegt diese Information nicht vor und es gibt glaube ich noch genug alte Leute, die durchaus noch auf eine Impfung warten. Es ist jetzt so viel hin und her gegangen,
Das müssen wir abwarten.
Und wie gesagt die Insidenzen sprechen halt eine klare Sprache äh die steigen in der Altersgruppe und äh ja
das sollte nicht sein und die bewegen sich halt auch auf einem Niveau, das halt schließen lässt, dass es da immer noch erhebliche Lücken im Impfschutz gibt bei achtzig plus.
Auf jeden Fall
Also logistisch versucht sie äh ist das sowieso alles auch noch am am justieren. Also nachdem jetzt diese Belieferung der Hausärzte überhaupt begonnen hat, war das wohl am Anfang so oder ist es äh sogar noch so und soll sich jetzt äh demnächst ändern in
einer Woche ungefähr, zehn Tagen
dass alle Ärzte einfach irgendwas zugeschickt bekommen haben. Das heißt, sie haben sowohl Astra Senika als auch Biontech bekommen, konnten aber nicht genau sagen, was sie jetzt eigentlich haben wollen
spricht die Kunden das nicht abstellen auf ihren spezifischen Bedarf, den sie jetzt bei ihren Patienten sehen. Das wird sich jetzt ändern ab dem sechsundzwanzigsten April
können die Ärzte auch speziell sagen, ich hätte gern davon so und so viel und davon so und so viel, sofern dann eben genug da ist.
Aktuell aber noch und äh bis zum sechsundzwanzigsten April wird das wohl auch noch so sein, gibt es wohl die Policy, dass Ärzte die gleiche Menge an Astra Sinica und Biontech
bestellen müssen oder geliefert bekommen.
Wobei derzeit Astra Sinnecke einfach schwieriger zu vermitteln ist. Also die Ärzte verbringen wohl relativ viel Zeit damit, um die den Leuten klarzumachen, wie da die Risiken sind, aber die Verunsicherung ist groß
die unter Umständen nicht gerechtfertigt ist, da sagen wir nachher noch was dazu, jetzt vielleicht nochmal zu den Impfstofflieferungen, gute Nachrichten gibt's dann von der EU.
Dass nämlich ähm mehr von Biotech kommt und zwar ist Biontech wohl in der Lage.
Und hat das jetzt auch zugesagt. Der EU bis Juni nicht nur die bisher vereinbarten zweihundert Millionen Dosen zu liefern, sondern tatsächlich zweihundertfünfzig Millionen.
Das bedeutet, da das ja immer anteilig nach Bevölkerungsanteilen ähm auf die europäischen,
Mitgliedsstaaten verteilt wird, dass für Deutschland nochmal weitere neun Millionen Dosen dazu kommen, die so vorher noch nicht auf der Liste standen,
Und darüber hinaus äh gibt es auch eine Vereinbarung, dass von Biontech,
zwanzig dreiundzwanzig eins Komma acht Milliarden Dosen noch kommen sollen. Sprich hier wird sichergestellt, dass man,
für eine weitere Bearbeitung der Pandemie dritte Impfung et cetera ähm auch genug Kapazität auf jeden Fall hat. Das sollte dann eigentlich auch erstmal reichen.
Ja, ich habe dann zumindest, ich glaube von einem der Birntech Gründer kam halt die Aussage und wegen muss man das vielleicht mit einem,
klein bisschen Vorsicht genießen, aber er geht davon aus, dass äh jedes Jahr äh,
eine Impfung nötig sein wird, eine angepasst, ja? Also er rechnet damit, dass wir das mit den Varianten nicht in den Griff kriegen,
könnte man auch sagen und äh oder nicht so bald in den Griff äh kriegen, sondern noch auf Jahre hinweg äh impfen müssen.
Ja
Das bringt uns so ein bisschen zu dem Thema, wie gut funktionieren denn die ganzen Impfstoffe eigentlich und jetzt gab's auch in den USA etwas Aufregung, denn die.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, es wird jetzt auch ein bisschen genauer hingeschaut, ne? Man muss ja auch immer erstmal wissen, auf was man eigentlich schaut. Und die ganze Aufregung rund um die Sinus Thrombosen, also Blutverklumpung im,
Hirn, in Hirnwehen, die hat jetzt auch die USA erreicht, wo ja Astra Senika immer noch nicht im Einsatz ist. Und jetzt ist offensichtlich auch der Johnson und Johnson im Stoff davon betroffen.
So, der Johnson und Johnson Impfstoff ist halt genauso wie der äh Sputning äh V und wie Astra Sinica,
halt so ein äh Vektorimpfstoff.
Ja und auch hier sind jetzt Fälle bekannt geworden und dementsprechend hat auch die FDA dort erstmal die Verimpung zurückgestellt. Also dort sind bereits sieben Millionen Dosen ausgespritzt worden quasi vergeben worden.
Und da gab es halt so vier oder so Fälle oder sieben. Genau, ich glaube, es waren sieben
Es ist so, dass das wörtliche Million, was dort aufgetreten ist, aber weil halt so viel Aufmerksamkeit auf dieses Thema,
weltweit gerade besteht und man sich ja nicht so richtig sicher ist, was jetzt eigentlich der Grund äh dafür zu sein scheint. Wurde auch da erstmal die Verimpung gestoppt.
Ich vermute mal, das wird auch wieder aufgenommen werden, ähm ob es dann auch zu so einer Einschränkung für bestimmte Altersgruppen kommen wird, kann ich derzeit noch nicht so richtig sagen.
Also auch hier sind es wieder Fälle äh vor allem bei Frauen in den ersten vierzehn Tagen nach der Impfung,
eine ist irgendwie gestorben, ein anderes im kritischen Zustand und ja, also im Prinzip dasselbe Bild, was sich hier auch bei Astra Sinica gebildet hat, aber eben mit sehr niedrigen.
Zahlen so, ne? Aber ist halt passiert. In dem Zusammenhang.
Gibt's jetzt auch eine neue Studie, interessanterweise von der Universität Ochsford? Also wo ja auch.
Der Astra Senika im Storf entwickelt wurde, wobei ich jetzt nicht sagen kann.
Diese Studie jetzt von denselben Leuten gemacht wurde, äh oder wie wie nah das sozusagen an diesem Prozess ist.
Die haben auf jeden Fall eine Studie veröffentlicht und die ist insofern sehr interessant, als das hier jetzt mal ein Blick,
auf eine sehr Großzahl von Kuvet neunzehn Patienten geöffnet wurde. Also das ist so quasi so eine,
Studie, die jetzt nicht durchgeführt wurde, sondern wo man sich auf Datenbanken verlässt. Das heißt, es gibt äh alle Cowit neunzehn Patienten letzten Endes weltweit, landen idealerweise in so großen Datenbanken,
äh konkret ist, dass die äh wie heißt das Ding noch gleich? Ähm.
Das war ja aber aufgeschrieben. Trinet X Datenbank, Electronic Health Records, Network.
Und da sind dann irgendwie fünfhunderttausend neunzehn Patienten drin äh gespeichert mit ihren Verläufen und was so an Nebenwirkungen aufgetreten ist und das kann man dann halt entsprechend untersuchen.
Beziehungsweise was äh die Anwendung von Astra Sinika betrifft ist hier dann auch tatsächlich glaube ich öfters Monitoring von der IMA zurückgegriffen gegriffen worden. Was hat man jetzt geguckt? Man hat einfach geschaut,
Wie oft kommen denn diese Hirnwindrumbosen oder Sinosthrombosen oder kurz CVT?
Denn jetzt insgesamt tatsächlich vor. Also ist das sozusagen nur ein Phänomen, was wir bei Impfstoffen sehen? Oder ist das etwas, was wir auch bei der Krankheit sehen?
Es war ja schon immer klar, Thrombosen an sich sind eine Begleiterscheinung von Coved neunzehn. Das ist etwas, was passiert, was öfter passiert, kann ich es gerade nicht beziffern, aber die,
normalen Anführungsstrichen, normalen Thrombosen, die also irgendwo im Körper auftreten, die ja auch häufiger auftreten. Die waren schon immer nochmal
separat zu behandeln. Hier geht's jetzt konkret nur um diese Sinus Thrombosen.
Und ja, stellt sich raus auch bei der Betrachtung kommt man auf eine Häufigkeit von neununddreißig von einer Million.
Ja, also wir haben eine halbe Million untersucht, also nehme ich mal an, haben so ungefähr so zwanzig Fälle, neunzehn, zwanzig Fälle gefunden. Ähm.
Und das ist sozusagen die Zahl will uns jetzt mitteilen.
Sinosthrombosen sind etwas, was diese Krankheit mit sich bringen kann.
Kann sein, das ist das, was was die Datenbanken hergeben, wenn man danach schaut, dass Leute bekommen, sich infizieren, die Krankheit ausbricht und dass sie dann im Verlauf dieser Krankheit auch.
Sinus Thrombosen entwickeln und das eben in der Häufigkeit von neununddreißig auf eine Million.
Bei Astra Sinneka, das worüber jetzt diskutiert wird und das, was halt jetzt auch bei Johnson Johnson berichtet wird und bei Johnson Johnson haben wir halt jetzt quasi einen Fall bei einer Millionen Impfung.
Ja, also es waren ja sieben Millionen sieben Fälle, also ne, haben wir quasi einer von einer Million, was derzeit gesehen wird. Man muss ja auch mal davon ausgehen, dass das nicht
immer alles perfekt erfasst wird und dass einem da auch ein paar durch die Lappen äh gehen und das mal was falsch erfasst wird, untererfasst wird, dass.
Ist immer alles möglich, ne? Von daher ist es die Zahlen jetzt auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber die sind zumindest schon mal ein Anhaltspunkt. Bars Rasinika reden wir derzeit von fünf.
Pro Million, ja? Im Vergleich Kowit,
Neununddreißig pro Millionen Astra Sinnika fünf pro Million. Und das ist das Interessante dabei, auch bei den MRNA-Impfstoffen.
Gibt es diese Fälle offenbar und zwar etwas geringer als bei Astra Senika vier von einer Million.
Sprich, um's nochmal die Zahlen ins Relation zu setzen, äh,
neunzehn hat quasi den zehnmal höheres Risiko für Sinostrombosen als eine MRN a basierte Impfung oder ein achtmal größeres Risiko als eine Astra Sinica-Impfung.
Das ist das ist sozusagen das, was diese Studie äh jetzt auf den Tisch legt. Das muss natürlich noch weiter äh überprüft und gegengecheckt werden. Nur das bedeutet im Prinzip.
Mann Wul davon ausgehen kann, dass einfach diese Sinostrombosen eine Begleiterscheinung einfach dieser Pandemie sind. Und,
Sie können durch die Krankheit induziert werden und sie können aber auch durch diese Impfung, also durch die Immunreaktion letzten Endes,
induziert werden. Und das ist ja auch eine der Thesen, die im Raum stehen, warum die überhaupt auftreten. Ja, also was ist eigentlich die Ursache? Warum passiert das? Und wir haben uns jetzt immer sehr auf die Astra Senika.
Konzentriert, weil da ist es aufgefallen, weil damit jetzt.
Vor allem in Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch in anderen Ländern früh junge Leute geimpft wurden und dann natürlich auch viele Frauen, weil wir eben im medizinischen Pflegebereich viel geimpft haben, deswegen ist es aufgefallen.
Aber es kann einfach äh sehr gut sein, dass das einfach ein Effekt ist, der damit zu tun hat,
wie das Immunsystem durch Kowit oder eben auch durch einen Impfstoff herausgefordert wird, weil der Improver letzten Endes ja auch dieses Bike-Protein oder Teile des Bike-Produktes Proteins anregt und dass das Immunsystem darauf reagiert.
Je nachdem in sehr seltenen Fällen kann es eben sein, dass diese Immunreaktion entweder auf Infektion oder auf äh äh Impfstoff.
Bei einzelnen Personen dazu führen kann, dass dass es diese Folgen gibt.
Ja
Also das ist jetzt so ein Zwischenergebnis. Ich will damit erstmal überhaupt nichts als belegt ansehen, weil,
wir wissen alle, morgen kommt wieder eine neue Studie raus und dann äh kann das auch alles schnell wieder relativiert werden, aber so stand heute macht es ein bisschen so den Eindruck, als ob diese Silosthrosen einfach eine Begleiterscheinung sind.
Dieser Pandemie, die durch unterschiedliche Dinge getriggert werden können, aber vor allem durch die Krankheit selber
durch die eigentliche Virusinfektion, die bringt sozusagen ein größeres Risiko und insgesamt sind diese Zahlen alle noch sehr niedrig, also neununddreißig von einer Million ist halt null Komma null null drei neun Prozent.
Ich meine, gut,
Man kann der Einwand war halt auch immer gut, man muss das eigentlich jetzt noch auf das Spezifische äh normale Risiko in den entsprechenden Altersgruppen nochmal
um äh rechnen, aber selbst dann äh glaube ich grundsätzlich.
Ist das Risiko zu Schaden zu kommen immer noch sehr viel größer durch die Krankheit selber.
Durch die definitiv, durch die durch die Krankheit auch äh und ähm,
es scheint auch nicht so die großen Unterschiede zwischen den Impfstoffen zu geben und dann sind eben diese Zahlen nach wie vor auch so klein, dass es immer noch schwierig ist wirklich statistisch den Zusammenhang überhaupt,
zu belegen. So, außer man geht dann spezifisch irgendwie in die Altersgruppen äh äh rein. Dann kann man irgendwie einen,
vielleicht aufmachen, aber äh ja,
Es äh scheint ja so zu sein, dass es äh egal ist, äh welchen
Impfstoff äh man darnimmt oder dass es keine großen Unterschiede gibt und wir werden wahrscheinlich das Problem bei anderen Impfstoffen auch noch sehen. Also interessant, wer halt,
ob's aus Russland irgendwas noch gibt zu ja ähm.
Und äh wie das irgendwie bei Sinowak eigentlich aussieht. So sieht man ist ja auch auch eine ganze Menge.
Verimpft worden und äh aber wahrscheinlich müssen wir uns,
drauf einstellen, dass es in diesen geringen äh Mengen schon in äh zeitlichen, vielleicht auch kausalen Zusammenhang in ganz wenigen Fällen äh mit der Impfung steht. So, ja,
Ähm ansonsten.
Viel mir noch so eine Sache auf jetzt äh mit dem Johnson und Johnson hatte ich mich noch nicht allzu viel.
Beschäftigt, gerade weil er hier bei uns ja auch noch nicht verimpft äh wurde. Aber.
Zumindest auf dem Papier scheint er auch nicht so wirksam zu sein wie die sowohl wie Astra Silika als auch wie.
Bayern Tech, Faiser, auch wenn natürlich Vergleich schwierig ist im Moment noch, aber das ist zumindest wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, die da aus den Studien rausgeplumpst äh sind, dann äh ja,
lese ich da was von zweiundsiebzig Prozent Effizienz bei Johnson und Johnson.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ja
schwierig zu interpretieren und äh natürlich äh ich sage mal äh kann man davon ausgehen, dass auch hundert Prozent
dass dass der hundert zu hundert Prozent gegen schwere Verläufe und Tod schützen wird oder
so gut wie hundert Prozent, aber für die Frage jetzt wie.
Ansteckend äh sind, sind geimpfte, auf die wir vielleicht auch noch kommen wollen äh oder wie gut ist der Schutz? Ja, ich meine
Mich fragte mich das nur, ob dann demnächst
es losgehen wird einen Run auf äh Astra Senika, weil die Leute nicht mit Johnson in Johnson bespritzt werden wollen, weil der nicht so gut,
So
Also die diese Effizienz, das hatten wir glaube ich hier auch schon mal, muss man ähm mit Vorsicht genießen, ne? Erstmal, das hast du ja schon angesprochen und ich denke, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig, das zu unterscheiden,
Effizienz im Bezug auf was. Das ist äh ja, diese Zahlen, die da in diesen Studien generiert werden, für die Zulassung beziehen sich auf.
Sind Leute nach der Impfung noch erkrankt.
Nicht sind sie schwer erkrankt, nicht sind sie daran gestorben, sondern sind sie überhaupt symptomatisch erkrankt.
Ist auch nicht haben sie sich infiziert und waren asymptomatisch, sondern es geht um Erkrankung. Die Erkrankung kann dann sehr, sehr, sehr smooth verlaufen.
Aber die Zahl steht dann auf dem Papier. Das heißt, wenn jetzt so ein Impfstoff auf zweiundsiebzig Prozent kommt.
Dann gab es vielleicht ein paar Fälle, aber wichtig ist, eben dann zu schauen.
Wozu haben diese Erkrankungen geführt? Haben die dazu geführt, dass hier Longkovit ist, schwerer Verlauf oder haben sie sogar zum Tod geführt? Und bisher.
Korrigiere mich, aber ich habe bisher noch nichts gesehen, wo Impfstoffe äh überhaupt durch Todesfälle aufgefallen wären.
Nein, äh keine Frage, wenn die Wahl.
Ja, ich wollte nicht dagegen argumentieren, ich wollte es nur nochmal klarstellen und noch zweite Sache, die auch noch mit reinkommt bei dieser Effizienzsache. Dieser Impfstoffe werden ja in the Wild getestet,
man startet eine Studie und es hängt immer sehr davon ab, wie eigentlich das Umfeld ist. Biontech und moderner.
Sind zu einem Zeitpunkt gestartet worden, wo eigentlich,
Die meisten Länder die erste Welle erstmal zurückgedrängt haben. Dieser Schockmoment, ja? Und erst nachdem diese Studien abgeschlossen waren, ging es mit den zweiten Wellen dann so weiter. Johnson und Johnson gehört schon zu den Impfstoffen
die dann eben später getestet wurden
dann entsprechend in einem wilderen Inzidenzumfeld unterwegs waren und das hat natürlich auf diese Zahlen auch einen Einfluss.
Und natürlich hat auch dieser Impfstoff,
einen großen Vorteil dahingehend, dass sie nur eine Dosis nötig ist. Das ist gerade dann, wenn man nicht sicherstellen kann bei bestimmten Patienten, dass die dann auch sagen, eine zweite Dosis bekommen
können, also was weiß ich, bei Reisenden oder wie auch immer, Obdachlosen oder anderen.
Oder Leute, die gerade aus dem Gefängnis entlassen werden.
Genau, das hatten wir auch, das heißt, dass es das ist halt dann, so sagen schon, auch nochmal ein entscheidender Vorteil oder Leute, die einfach nicht den Hessel
haben wollen und man kann davon ausgehen, dass sich der Impfschutz, also diese.
Zweiundsiebzig Prozent oder wie viel ist auch immer sein mögen, wahrscheinlich auch relativ schnell aufbauen so. Aber das äh ja nichtsdestotrotz.
Und das sollte man vielleicht jetzt auch nicht der Ehrlichkeit halber einfach nicht verschweigen, äh liegt es halt nahe, dass
einen Impfstoff, wo zwei Dosen geimpft werden am Ende ja
'ne höhere Wirksamkeit erreichen kann als ein Impfstoff wo ich nur eine Dosis brauche, mag sein, dass sich das irgendwann in der Zukunft wird das auch hinkriegen, dass wir alle nur eine Dosis brauchen, aber so stellt sich mir das.
Im Moment äh einfach da, das heißt,
wer halt wie nur auch nur einmal zum Pieksen will, äh super. Äh Johnson und Johnson.
Ideal so,
Ansonsten, ja, wenn man dann schon irgendwie pingelig ist und aufgrund von Gerüchten äh sozusagen äh lieber eine Wahl treffen möchte, äh wo dann,
Ja, werden wir da auch noch Spaß kriegen?
Im Baum.
Ja, also mit diesem wann kann man sich jetzt infizieren und wann nicht? Also da gibt's ja wirklich äh verschiedenste Meldungen. Wir hatten jetzt, glaube ich, in wo war das überhaupt, in Leichlingen.
Der Name. Äh gab's ein.
Ausbruch von Corona in einem Altenheim, wo eine ganze Menge Leute bereits geimpft waren und auch zweimal schon geimpft waren. Also komplett durchgeimpft worden, so wie ich das so sehe. Insgesamt betrifft es sechzig Leute.
Die meisten davon halt Bewohner und dann äh Mitarbeiter, wie sich das aufteilt, es wurde hier leider nicht berichtet. Auf jeden Fall gab's insgesamt siebzehn Infektionen und davon waren vierzehn Leute,
bereits äh geimpft.
Also neunzig Prozent der Beschäftigten waren geimpft und fünfundneunzig Prozent der Bewohner waren geimpft und trotzdem kam's halt nochmal zu äh Infektionen.
Also vierzehn, genau, ist nochmal zu sagen, vierzehn Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner sind infiziert, zwölf davon geimpft. Also es haben sich halt von den vierzehn waren zwölf geimpft.
Genau und dann mit den Mitarbeitern, also hast du insgesamt siebzehn Infektionen und vierzehn ähm davon waren geimpft. Also, ob's jetzt Mitarbeiter oder,
Bewohner sind für dich jetzt an der Stelle irrelevant, also relativ viele, wo man ja sagen würde, wie kann denn das sein, dass hier irgendwie ah was nicht ein Drittel ist es nicht, aber ein bisschen weniger sich äh dann trotzdem noch haben,
infizieren können.
Über ein Vierteljahr.
Wobei auch hier muss man dann dazu sagen, ja Infektion wurde festgestellt, aber soweit ich den äh Bericht verstanden habe, auch jetzt keine schweren Verläufe. Ne, also auch hier haben die Leute Symptome, aber wenn vermutlich äh keinen Schaden daran nehm.
Also ich denke das Wichtigste äh was man einfach mitnehmen kann, so ist eine gute Nachricht,
nämlich das äh so wie es aussieht ja die Impfungen schützen,
vor, äh, ja, Tod oder schweren Verläufen, das ist die positive Nachricht
die andere, eigentlich ist es gar keine negative Nachricht, sondern eigentlich ist es etwas, was schon immer völlig klar war, aber offenbar irgendwie nicht allen völlig klar äh ist äh so, dass man natürlich wieder,
dem Wunsch, dass doch bald möglichst alles äh äh vorbei äh sein. Möge wird dann gerne äh doch,
die Impfung so ein bisschen ja überschätzt äh vielleicht an manchen,
Stellen unterschätzt an anderen Stellen, aber äh der der eigentliche Punkt ist erstens.
Man kann sich auch mit Corona infizieren, wenn man geimpft ist.
Und äh die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist zwar deutlich geringer, dass das passiert, aber je nachdem äh ja in dem Fall äh waren's halt äh ja.
Sagen, dass es ein Drittel bis ein Viertel
derer ungefähr in der in der Gegend lag das so die die Quote in dem Haus, wenn man davon ausgeht irgendwie nur kein neunzig Prozent waren waren geimpft dann ja also rund
fünfundzwanzig Prozent sagen.
Scheinen sich zumindest in diesem Fall der geimpften auch einfach anstecken,
zu können. So,
und dann, was hier in dem Fall unklar ist, ist, wo sie sich angesteckt haben, ob sie sich jetzt untereinander, also es ist speziell, ob jetzt.
Auch ähm geimpfte.
So viel Virus entwickelt haben, dass sie andere geimpfte oder über oder andere ungeimpfte äh angesteckt haben, dass,
ja hoffe ich sollte bald auch unter.
Klar sein oder erforscht sein, hoffe ich so. Ähm,
aber nichts genaues weiß man noch nicht und es ist auf jeden Fall eine eine dringende Mahnung äh so auch wenn man geimpft ist, auch wenn man zweimal geimpft ist Maske tragen
Aus zwei Gründen, weil man will sich zum einen trotzdem nicht anstecken und man kann immer noch einen Verlauf haben mit.
Unangenehmen Symptomen, sage ich mal. Ähm.
Und aber vor allem natürlich um andere, die noch nicht geimpft äh sind zu schützen, weil das ist natürlich gerade, wo
nicht jeder Zugang zu Impfstoffen hat, ist das äh eigentlich
auch 'ne große Verantwortung dann von denen die jetzt das Privileg haben aufgrund ihrer Gesundheit oder ihres Alters jetzt vorzeitig
oder mit Priorität äh geimpft werden äh zu dürfen. Also oder auch gerade bei jungen Leuten, also.
Ja, ich finde das äh eine ziemlich miese Nummer, wenn äh jemand äh geimpft ist und äh dann einfach unvorsichtig und dann andere einfach eventuell ansteckt. So, so klein.
Wahrscheinlichkeit sein mag, sie ist nicht null und sie ist wahrscheinlich größer als die meisten denken, dass sowas passieren kann.
In dem Zusammenhang stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, wie Variantenresistent ist das, jetzt gab's da eine Meldung aus Israel,
bei ähm Leuten, die auch dort mit Biontech oder moderner geimpft waren, ähm da gab's geringe Zahlen, auch was ähm bisschen.
Überraschend war für die Leute, die sich das angeschaut haben, war das wohl diese Südafrika-Variante,
deutlich häufiger auftrat, als sie das so aus den Zahlen und der Verbreitung, die sie da aufgestellt haben, äh, erwartet hätten.
Ja, also nochmal, Leute sind äh geimpft gewesen und haben sich dann eben auch wieder infiziert. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, wie das dann festgestellt wurde, wie die Studie da aufgestellt war
nur und es handelt sich ja auch um eine geringe Zahl, die ich gerade nicht quantifizieren kann, nur das Verhäl.
Hundertfünfzig, sie haben hundertfünfzig Proben, also hundertfünfzig positive äh getestet, die halt eben teils asymphotisch infiziert waren, teils.
Erkrankt waren, so äh obwohl sie bereits die erste oder sogar beide Impfungen bekommen hatten. So, also das war sozusagen das das Kriterium, positiver Test.
Nach ein oder zwei Impfdosen.
Mhm. Genau und.
Aber das eigentlich überraschende war nicht, dass sie sich mit irgendwas wieder infiziert haben. Haben wir ja gerade auch durchgesprochen, das ist bekannt, dass das möglich ist. Die Zahlen waren auch gering, nur die Verteilung der Varianten hat sie halt ein bisschen überrascht,
und die Fragestellung, die damit aufkam, war, hat jetzt diese Südafrika-Variante einen Vorteil.
Weil man sozusagen gegen den anderen im Stoff äh gegen den gegen die anderen Varianten geimpft ist.
Und ein Verdacht, der dann sozusagen auch mit äh geführt wird. Das wird hier in diesem Artikel als Antigenerbsünde äh bezeich
ich weiß noch nicht so richtig, was sie von diesem Begriff halten soll, aber was so ein bisschen die eine These ist, die so im Raum ist, dass es vielleicht sein
könnte unter Umständen vielleicht, dass wenn man jetzt für ähm eine Variante geimpft ist.
Und sich der Körper da mit seiner Immunreaktion drauf eingeschossen hat und sagt so okay alles klar ja B eins eins sieben oder Wildtyp irgendwie kenne ich, hab ich schon mal gesehen
glaube ich zumindest schon mal gesehen zu haben. Äh mir kann keiner was, ich habe jetzt hier irgendwie entsprechende Antikörper aufgebaut.
Und B-Zellen eingerichtet und was nicht alles. Jetzt kommt irgendwie die Südafrikavariante und sagt, ich klopfe aber hier nochmal an und ich infiziere dich jetzt mal so ein bisschen. Die Fragestellung, die im Raum steht, ist.
Kann es sein, dass eben gegen diese Varianten der Körper gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist äh eine entsprechende Gegenwehr aufzustellen
weil er sozusagen auf den anderen eingeschossen ist und der Abstand zu dem neuen Virus so gering ist, dass das da sogar noch ein Nachteil entsteht
Also großes Fragezeichen hinter der Geschichte, dazu verstehe ich auch äh zu wenig davon, aber den Link haben wir,
mal mit reingeworf.
Also.
Halte das jetzt weiß ich nicht erstmal spontan sagen würde ich das erstmal bezweifeln.
Dass dem so ist, weil eigentlich ist es ihn ja grundsätzlich erstmal umgekehrt, je ähnlicher einen,
Virus ist mit irgendwas bekanntem, äh was der Körper schon mal gemacht hat
umso ja besser oder schneller kann er das das auch bekämpfen, weil die Sachen halt schon eben auch durchaus,
wirken, also ja.
Griff, ich glaube, Kreuzimmunität ist da. Der Begriff und das wäre quasi irgendwie so Gegenteil von von.
Ja Kreuzimität und ja.
Wir haben's mal erwähnt, wir beobachten das. Mal gucken, äh was dabei rauskommt. Wenn da überhaupt jemals was bei rauskommt.
Jetzt haben wir irgendwie viel über ähm.
Ja, über Impfstoffe geredet, die alle entwickelt werden sollen und wo wir die ganze Zeit danach harren, das Meer zugelassen wird, dass mehr getestet wird und dass wir vor allem auch Bevölkerungsgruppen mit äh mit impfen können, die bisher noch nicht
geimpft werden, wie zum Beispiel Kinder.
Und da stellt sich natürlich so ein bisschen die Frage, wo kommen denn diese ganzen Studien her? Studien an Impfstoffen heißt, Leute lassen sich impfen.
Nebenan so 'ne Studie teil und wenn's halt keine Leute gibt die daran teilnehmen dann gibt's auch keine Studie.
Einfache Geschichte und da jetzt vor allem das das Thema Kinder in den Fokus gerät.
Wurden wir darauf hingewiesen,
das äh ist hier eine entsprechende Programme gibt, wo man sich dann auch registrieren lassen kann. Wenn man denn sozusagen dran teilnehmen möchte oder seine Kinder an so einem Programm teilnehmen lassen.
Möchte.
Das ist natürlich eine Frage, die muss jeder für sich selber beantworten und natürlich letzten Endes auch für die Kinder beantworten. Ähm aber wir verweisen einfach mal hier auf eine entsprechende Webseite. Es macht so den Eindruck.
Das richtig überblicke, dass die Universitätsklinik in Köln hier eine führende Rolle hat und zwar nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch in Europa. Ähm WWW Punkt Impfstudienstrich Corona Punkt DE ist die Webseite
wo man sich registrieren kann, wenn man bereit ist, daran teilzunehmen
Das Ganze gibt's auch noch auf EU-Ebene, wird aber letzten Endes glaube ich auch von der Uni
Universitätsklinik in Köln wiederführend betrieben. Da heißt es dann ganz fancy Veccelerate
Punkt net und äh die Links findet ihr auch in den Shownotes.
Sprich, da könnte man dann auch EU-weit Leute drauf hinweisen, dass sie sich darauf dran registrieren, damit es eben im Studien geben kann.
Und wir sehen können, wie Impfstoffe bei Kindern wirken oder eben auch bei anderen Altersgruppen ist jetzt gar nicht mal nur auf Kinder beziehen, aber das ist natürlich jetzt das nächste, was uns vor allem eben fehlt und,
da hättet ihr die Möglichkeit dran teilzunehmen, wenn ihr denn das äh wenn ihr dafür die Verantwortung bereit seid zu übernehmen.
Mhm. Und,
ist es wohl so, dass Kinder ab oder Jugendliche eigentlich ab vierzehn Jahren das auch selbst entscheiden können. Also ich glaube äh wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, können die sich da erstmal selbst äh registrieren und,
auch noch Hinweise durch die Registrierung dort verpflichtet man sich erstmal zu nichts, sondern man wird dann eben erstmal informiert darüber,
worum es geht und kann sich dann sagen auch nochmal informiert entscheiden so ob man,
das möchte oder nicht oder ob man dann lieber sagt, ah nee, lass das lieber irgendwie Brasilianer oder die Südafrikaner äh äh machen, so die sollen mal lieber ihre
Kinder dahin schicken, so. Ja kann man sich auch auf den Standpunkt stellen
aber ähm ja äh am Ende des Tages klar ist es eine einezelne gewissens äh Entscheidung oder man sollte da eine informierte Entscheidung äh denke ich treffen,
ist auch kein,
festes Impfstoffversprechen, einmal in dem Sinne, weil äh man auch Pech haben kann oder Glück, je nachdem äh und man kommt in eine Placebo-Gruppe.
So ist es halt, aber äh ja, es ist, ich sage mal, grundsätzlich äh so eine Möglichkeit, wenn vielleicht erstmal Jugendliche.
Der Meinung sind, ja, wir sollten irgendwie hier auch,
mit Verantwortung äh übernehmen, das vielleicht auch andere Jugendliche dann eine Impfung bekommen können, ist das eine Möglichkeit.
Genau, wenn man auf der Webseite rumklickt, sieht man, wie sie das äh wie sich das auch zahlenmäßig äh verteilt.
Zum Beispiel für Deutschland sind sechsundzwanzigtausendzweiundachtzig Personen registriert und ähm davon wurden,
Dreitausendvierhundertvierunddreißig eine Studie empfohlen, also man registriert sich, sagt sozusagen hier, ich bin X Alter sowieso, Geschlecht und so weiter.
Dann wenn die Studien kommen, dann werden aus dieser Datenbank entsprechende Anfragen generiert, so hier, du hast dich doch registriert und würdest vielleicht gerne an einer Studie teilnehmen. Wir hätten da vielleicht was, äh, willst du da nicht mitmachen.
Gibt's hier so eine kleine Heatmap auch, wo man sehen kann, den größten Zuspruch gibt's ohne große Überraschung in Köln.
Ja genau. Impf.
Bereitschaft ist natürlich jetzt auch so ein Thema. Und ich habe so in letzten Tagen ein bisschen,
Na ja ähm beunruhigt wir vielleicht jetzt ein großes Wort, aber schon etwas verwundert auf die Zahlen in Israel geschaut.
Wir hatten ja in Israel dieser einmalige Situation, dass Bayon Tech gesagt hat, okay, alles klar, Impfstoff kann es kein Problem, wir liefern hier so viel wie wir können und ihr könnt hier mehr oder weniger eure.
Euer Land in Rekordzeit durchimpfen und das hat ja auch super funktioniert, die Kampagne ist extrem gut angelaufen und in Israel wurde so in den ersten Monaten äh so pro Monat zwanzig Prozent äh im,
äh Impfungen, also zwanzig Prozent der Bevölkerung pro Monat wurden äh geimpft
der Zeit wenig überraschend ist diese Zahl natürlich dann etwas zurückgegangen, also anfangs gab's natürlich da eine große Euphorie und 'n Ansturm und natürlich werden vor allem dann auch die
pulerablen Gruppen geimpft werden und in zunehmenden Maße
Jetzt ist halt mittlerweile so, es kann sich quasi jeder einfach melden, sagen, hier ich will jetzt mal werden, wo gehe ich hin, zack, bumm und dann hat man auch schon die Spritze äh im Arm.
Die Zahlen gehen aber mittlerweile runter und ähm die Erstimpfung sind jetzt im letzten Monat, dann wirklich nur noch um.
Zwei Prozent gestiegen. Das ist gerade mal von fünfundfünfzig Komma vier auf siebenundfünfzig Komma vier Prozent.
Angestiegen und man sieht auch, dass die Zahl der vollständig geimpften sich jetzt immer mehr der Erstimpfung annähert.
Ja, am Anfang ging's natürlich entsprechend anders auseinander und es bedeutet.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet. Auf jeden Fall kann man sehen, dass die Begeisterung sich jetzt noch impfen zu lassen, irgendwie ein wenig abgeflout zu sein scheint. Da hast du natürlich in Israel so ein bisschen dieses
spezifische Probleme doch relativ großen orthodoxen.
Die da wohl einige Zurückhaltungen haben, wir sind nicht sonderlich überrascht. Ähm aber auch bei.
Den Jugendlichen scheint es wohl da entsprechende Zurückhaltung,
zu geben, also in jüngeren Generationen, auch um zwanzig und dreißig herum, die halt so oft im Standpunkt sind, so ach na ja, mein Risiko ist ja so gering und
die halt auch die ganzen Meldungen um Impfkomplikationen für sich so ausrechnen, so nach dem Motto, ja, nee, das Risiko muss jetzt nicht eingehen, ich habe gar kein großes Risiko.
Plus,
Ich meine, ein Faktor könnte natürlich sein und das ist jetzt wiederum die positive Nachricht, dass in Israel die Institutionen äh jetzt äh mittlerweile, ich glaube unter zwanzig auf hunderttausend
gefallen sind so größenordnungsmäßig.
Und äh ja ähnlich sieht's auch in den UKE aus gerade.
Wobei das natürlich glaube ich auch in beiden Ländern schon so eine gewisse Kombination aufs Log down und Impfung war.
Ja dieses beide auch gleich auf irgendwie ukay und und Israel. Mhm.
Also das äh zumindest ähm sage ich mal, verspricht dann zumindest also, dass eine Kombination aus Logdown und Impfungen dann doch.
Die Zahlen recht schnell auch nach unten bringen könnte, wenn man den ja tatsächlich irgendwo hinkommt und ähm,
Ich mein UK hat es geschafft halt sagen auf achtzig runterzukommen und.
Dann eben auch nicht wieder in eine dritte Welle äh zu gehen, so wie wir, ja.
Also das ging da und zwar sind die innerhalb.
Von ja was war das bis zum eigentlich fünften März.
Von Januar bis März haben die's halt geschafft äh sagen weiter nach unten äh zu fahren und nach unten zu kommen während wir halt wieder in die falsche Richtung abgebogen sind.
Und das von einer viel viel höheren Institut, also.
Ja, die sind von im Prinzip von ungefähr ja siebenhundertfünfzig oder so sind die im Januar gestartet.
Und äh ja sind jetzt auf zwanzig runter. Das hätten wir auch haben können, ne,
hinten, also wir waren auf dem auf derselben Dreiektorie, so, die haben uns halt einfach nur überholt und äh das äh ja liegt nicht allein an den Impfungen, ja.
Das äh oder äh nur zu einem kleineren Teil an den Impfungen jetzt, der Endspurt gerade, da machen die sich sicher bemerkbar, aber das Ganze äh oder jetzt machen sie sich wahrscheinlich dort langsam bemerkbar.
Ja aber ja bei uns geht sowas offenbar nicht oder bisher ging das halt nicht.
Trotzdem mache ich mir so ein bisschen Sorgen, dass nicht genug Leute äh dann quasi
sagen, okay, ich lasse mich jetzt auch noch impfen, weil ist ja alles so schön. Die Kaffees haben doch wieder offen, wozu soll ich mich jetzt noch äh impfen lassen. Wir haben noch niedrige Instinzen, was kann denn schon passieren, ne? Und wir wissen halt und das haben wir ja jetzt auch schon ausführlich diskutiert. Es kann eine ganze Menge passieren. Es können neue Varianten kommen und äh vor allem
kann es sich dann eben an einzelnen Orten dann doch eben wieder zu so einem äh Infektionsgeschehen aufblähen, was jetzt vielleicht
insgesamt nicht riesig wird, aber zumindest Leute konkret bedroht und eben einfach dieses einfach auch nicht dafür sorgt, dass das Virus aus der Gesellschaft kommt,
dass es einfach auf einer auf einer.
Ebene rumort, wo es einfach immer noch da ist und immer wieder noch Leute äh äh erwischen kann und letzten Endes dazu führt, dass man eben dann
einfach doch nicht alles öffnen kann, doch nicht irgendwie die Grenzen öffnen kann, doch irgendwie nicht die Wirtschaft äh so laufen lassen kann, wie man will.
Also es kann, genau, es kann gut sein, dass es dann irgendwo vereinzelt in bestimmten Gegenden dann plötzlich wieder zu neuen Ausbrüchen äh kommt, die man dann hoffentlich eingefangen kriegt, weil sie nur lokal sind
aber ähm ja,
wie gesagt, mit den mit den Varianten ist nicht zu spaßen und klar kann man sich drauf verlassen, dass der Impfstoff jetzt alles richtet, so und vielleicht,
hoffen, vielleicht wird er auch alles richten, aber mir ist das zu unsicher, ja, weil äh wir wissen nicht, ob der Impfstoff alles richten wird. Im Moment sieht's super aus, ja,
aber es gibt ebenso diese kleinen Warnzeichen, die wir ja eben auch auch genannt hatten, äh die man nicht völlig ignorieren sollte, so nämlich
dass ja bisher zumindest in Deutschland war uns der Virus eigentlich ständig voraus, also der Virus war
schneller als die Politik, ja? Er hat sich immer wieder was Neues einfallen lassen.
Und vor allem.
Es gibt ja auch noch andere Länder. So, ähm zum Beispiel gibt es Taiwan und da sieht es, ich verstehe das noch nicht so vollständig auf und den Bericht, den ich hier äh zitiere und gesehen habe, ist es so.
Die haben,
Wir haben ja sozusagen so eine Null-Inzidenz, ne? Das ist so ein Zerokovicland, die haben einfach zugemacht und äh wollen natürlich den Zustand auch nicht immer bleiben. Aber ist halt so ein bisschen so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, eine Insel der Glückseeligen
weil sie einfach mit diesen unmittelbaren Auswirkungen schon gar nicht eben mit hohen Todeszahlen äh nichts zu tun haben. Trotzdem gibt's da jetzt Impfstoffe.
Nur werden die halt nicht gut angenommen. Also das Land hat jetzt gerade mal dreihundertsiebzehntausend Astra Sinika Dosen erhalten.
Ich glaube, das muss man mal ein bisschen in äh Relation setzen, wie viele Leute in Taiwan eigentlich äh tatsächlich äh leben, ähm Republik äh China heißt das ja so schön.
Ähm hat immerhin dreiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen Einwohner.
Ja, die haben jetzt gerade mal dreihunderttausend Impfstoffe bekommen, übrigens Astra Senika. Am zweiundzwanzigsten März, also vor einem Monat,
Davon sind gerade mal siebenundzwanzigtausend verimpft worden. Und die haben jetzt irgendwie Angst, dass sie sogar diese geringe Zahl von Impfstoffen nicht loswerden
und mich wundert, dass ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen äh bis der verfällt Ende Mai oder Mitte Juni spätestens waren so zwei Lieferungen und Mitte Juni ist dann die letzte äh abgelau.
Also sehr merkwürdig, ein Land, was eigentlich so eine hohe Awareness gezeigt hat, dass die äh zumindest derzeit noch nicht auch mit äh hohen Impfungszahlen überzeugen.
Deswegen stellt sich für mich eben diese Frage kann es sein, dass am Ende die.
Diese gefühlte Wahrnehmung, dieser Pandemie äh am Ende komplett verhindern kann, dass man sie überhaupt ordentlich bekämpfen kann.
Tja,
Also ähm das passt halt so ein bisschen auch zu Nachrichten aus Australien. Äh die, an die ich mich gerade erinnert äh habe.
Ja, also ich sage erstmal was in Australien gerade äh los ist, Australien überlegt gerade,
auch wenn die Bevölkerung vollständig durchgeimpft ist hm die Grenzen geschlossen zu halten.
Und auch in Australien ist im Moment so die Impfbereitschaft hält sich auch dort in Grenzen und der Hintergrund ist, weil sich die Leute sagen, okay also äh,
die Krankheit ist bei uns gerade nicht im Moment und das werden sich die Leute in Tailla äh in Taiwan vielleicht
auch sagen okay, das bedroht mich jetzt gerade im Moment nicht unmittelbar und wir haben eigentlich Zeit, uns erstmal anzugucken
wie das Ganze so läuft mit den Impfstoffen und wie die so wirken oder nicht wirken und vielleicht gibt's ja dann demnächst auch eine neue äh Variante, dann nehmen wir doch lieber gleich die, weil im Moment haben wir halt keine Not,
so Australien dagegen also was dort äh sie offenbar überlegen,
hängt auch mit den Varianten zusammen, also auch äh die haben halt äh im Moment so gut wie kein,
Kovit im Land, also ein bisschen hier und da äh so, aber sie haben's halt unter Kontrolle und.
Ja, haben halt jetzt Angst, dass selbst wenn die Bevölkerung durchgeimpft ist und sie machen die Grenzen
auf das dann halt äh ja vielleicht neue Varianten gegen die die Impfung nicht gut genug hilft,
äh dann plötzlich unkontrolliert das Land äh überschwemmen. Ja,
Das ist so gerade äh was äh so die
Politik überlegt, ob es dazu kommen wird, wird man sehen, ob sie dem Druck standhalten können, dann dann zu öffnen, wird sicherlich auch davon abhalten.
Wie das insgesamt in anderen Ländern läuft und wie das mit der Variantenentwicklung aussieht
aber ja die haben gerade, ich sage mal, Angst oder Respekt äh vor den Varianten
und wenn man sich überlegt, dass sie zu den Ländern gehören, die das bisher ganz gut hingekriegt haben, lohnt es sich zumindest
ja
einfach denen mal zuzuhören, was den so durch den durch den Kopf geht. Keine Ahnung, ob das oder nein.
Ob sie, ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt wirklich Paranoid äh sind an der Stelle, aber ähm,
glaube eher nicht. Ich denke das ist schon ja unklar,
da ist auf jeden Fall eine Gefahr, die sich bisher noch nicht ausschließen lässt. So äh denke ich.
Kann man das das sehen und ja,
und wenn man halt sich den Treckrekord anguckt, wie wir vorgel
gegangen sind bisher, also wenn äh die Varianten ein Problem geben werden, dann sind wir wahrscheinlich auch diejenigen, die da wieder voll reinrennen werden in das Varianten.
Ja, wir haben grad nochmal geschaut, also tatsächlich also Australien, da ist jetzt komischerweise bei Auerworld Indata seit März seit einem Monat überhaupt gar keine Updates für Impfungen.
Zu sehen. Also haben die das jetzt komplett eingestellt oder was? Und Neuseeland impft aber.
Ist aber da auch gerade mal bei, na ja, etwas mehr als zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung, also wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wenig.
Bei in gewisser Hinsicht müssen sie es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben. Ja ähm die haben ja jetzt mit Australien zusammen auch so eine Green Zone.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt mittlerweile von Australien nach Neuseeland, kannst halt problemlos rüberfliegen ohne irgendwelche Quarantäne an der Grenze et cetera.
Während wenn du halt aus anderen Ländern kommst, dann kommst halt entweder gar nicht rein oder halt eben nur unter sehr starken äh Auflagen und so halten sie sich da irgendwie äh frei. Ich meine ich habe keine gute Wahrnehmung von dieser Region der Welt
Kann mir vorstellen, dass dass ohnehin Länder sind, die.
Also wo zwar Tourismus schon eine Rolle spielt, aber wahrscheinlich der Großteil des Tourismus ist halt eher so ein Inlands äh Tourismus beziehungsweise Neuseeland in Australien. Besuchen sich irgendwie
gegenseitig, weil bevor du irgendwo anders bist, musst du schon ganz schön lange reisen. Ist halt weit weg und von daher mag das auch so eine.
Ja, macht das sozusagen auch so eine.
So eine so eine Strategie sein, dass sie sagen, ja okay, nee, wir impfen jetzt hier einfach mal einen normalen Zustand und der Rest der Welt braucht ja sowieso noch eine Weile,
bis wir die wieder ins Land lassen, äh warten wir einfach nochmal mehr ab. Wir haben uns jetzt mit dieser Situation arrangiert
An dieser Stelle im Übrigen sollten wir auch Zuhörer in Australien und in Neuseeland haben, da wäre ich dann über Feedback dann doch mal. Äh da wäre ich ein Feedback sehr interessiert.
Also ich habe gerade mal äh sagen geguckt äh.
Darf der australischen äh Regierungs äh Webseite äh.
So eins Komma vier zwo Millionen Dosen haben sie verabreicht so und sechzigtausend in den letzten vierundzwanzig Stunden. Also sie liegen da,
doch eigentlich ja ein Tempo vor. Ich meine wir sind in Australien vierzehn Millionen Leute oder so. Wohnt ja kaum jemand, Johannes. Äh.
Ähm eins Komma vier zwo Millionen äh.
Okay, na gut, dann ist also Auerhold in Detail äh ganz anders informiert.
Nee, fünfundzwanzig Komma drei sechs sind das, das war das habe ich noch in der Schule gelernt. Ähm irgendwie die die Zahl von vierzehn.
Millionen, ja, das war genau vierzehn Millionen war äh.
Ach so, in der eins Komma genau eins Komma drei sechs Millionen haben sie verimpft, genau, richtig. Ich hatte hier gerade die falsche Einstellung äh gewählt, genau. Ja.
Okay, also von, also sie sind, das heißt, sie sind irgendwo bei was fünf, sechs Prozent äh.
Ähm nach Dosen. Ja, warte mal, wir können das hier nach People wechseln.
Also ja, Neuseeland hat zwei Komma zwei Prozent und.
Komischerweise äh okay, dass es diese Zahl, die sich hier komischerweise nicht aktualisiert, deswegen kann ich dir das gerade nicht äh sagen, aber Dosis.
Da gibt's eine Information. Und das sind halt fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung nach Dosen.
Etwas weniger, weil sich das ja dann irgendwie auch äh aufteilt. Also auch nur ein paar Prozent.
Okay, lass uns da nicht so lange äh drauf ähm rumhängen.
Kommen wir nochmal zu einer anderen Geschichte, die so ein bisschen äh ja immer noch so ein bisschen so ein Backborner Thema ist, nämlich wie kann man denn die Krankheit eigentlich behandeln
Und abgesehen von dieser einen Phase eins Studie eines vielversprechenden Medikaments in Israel, was wir hier vor ein paar Wochen mal besprochen haben
war jetzt eigentlich im Bereich der Medikamentierung, gab's irgendwie nicht so viel. Also so große Durchbrüche waren nicht zu feiern und alles, was ja so im letzten Jahr gehandelt wurde von Hydro äh Chyroquinen und ähm.
Hydroxe hier.
Hydroxiklogin und ähm was nicht alles ausprobiert wurde, auch an existierenden Medikamenten war ähm ja nicht so.
Waren alles nicht so die Bringer, ne.
Ja. Ich meine, gut, man hat gleichzeitig aber jetzt glaube ich so in den Kliniken eine Kombination aus ja ich sag mal zugelassenen Medikamenten oder für andere äh.
Dinge zugelassenen Medikamenten äh glaube ich gefunden, wie,
Blutverdünner und ähm ja immun äh äh Hämmer äh sage ich mal äh die offenbar eine gewisse Wirkung äh zeigen.
Aber ja ich hab mir angeschaut ob sich im Laufe der Zeit irgendwas,
verändert hat äh bei der Sterblichkeit und äh Zahlen sind zwar ganz schön verrauscht, aber so richtig einen einen Effekt, dass sich das äh jetzt,
seit der ersten Welle irgendwie signifikant verändert hätte, dass also signifikant mehr Leute gerettet werden könnten, den Eindruck hatte ich nicht.
Genau, aber jetzt gibt es was Neues und zwar gibt's äh wieder eine Studie aus Ochsford und zwar äh in diesem Fall zu einem Asthma-Spray
gibt es äh verschiedene zur Auswahl, aber Einwirkstoff, der da schon seit langem zum Einsatz kommt, heißt Bude, Sonit. Und Bullisonic äh scheint nun tatsächlich,
wirklich eine eine interessante und sehr effiziente Wirkung zu haben auf den Krankheitsverlauf.
Asthmaspray, das sind so diese kleinen Spraydosen, die man sich so senkrecht vor die Nase äh hält und sich dann so Hübe einverleibt, so Stöße, so.
Man hat das vielleicht mal äh gesehen bei anderen Leuten, weil sie nicht selber davon betroffen seid
nimmt man dann irgendwie ein oder zweimal am Tag was davon, das kann dann eben diese Asthma Probleme reduzieren und,
Leute auch vor Stickungen äh retten
und stellt sich raus, dass äh das wohl schon in China mal aufgefallen ist und es gibt auch entsprechende Berichte aus Österreich, von Ärzten, die so wirklich an der Front
unterwegs sind und die das auch teilweise schon zum Einsatz gebracht haben, aber man hat es halt auch gesehen bei der Untersuchung der Zahlen, welche Gruppen sind jetzt hier betroffen, dass man auf einmal so einen Einbruch hatte von den Sterbezahlen
und den Zahlen der schweren Verläufe bei Leuten, die eben dieses Asthma-Mittel einnehmen.
Beziehungsweise man hat's erstmal gesehen bei Asthmatikern und dann hat man halt gesehen, okay, warum eigentlich? Und äh hat dann eben festgestellt, dass die
Boulesonidhaltigen äh Asthmamittel äh offensichtlich einen Unterschied machen. Und das Ganze ist jetzt richtig in so einem randomisierten, kontrollierten Versuch
in Ochsford überprüft worden.
Und so in äh Phase zwei und da gibt's ein entsprechendes äh Paper jetzt dazu, hundertsechsundvierzig Patienten wurden dort äh behandelt
die alle so im Mittel seit drei Tagen an Symptomen leiden.
Also es stellt sich halt raus, dass diese Wirkung von diesem Boulesonid vor allem eben in dieser ersten Woche greift. Also nach Symptomenbeginn, wenn man eben bis zu sieben Tage
spätestens anfängt zweimal am Tag
so einen Stoß von diesem äh Asthmaspray einzunehmen, dass sich dann eben die Chancen doch erheblich verbessern.
Hier ist davon die Rede, dass es äh zu neunzig Prozent gegen schwere Verläufe wirksam war, ja? Also, Leute kriegen Covet.
Und dann wird gesagt, okay, alles klar, du hast Kove.
Ist jetzt ein paar Tage her, ja, nicht länger als eine Woche. Hier hast du Asthma-Spray zweimal am Tag, hau dir mal was rein davon.
Das wurde dann eben entsprechend untersucht und siehe da im äh im Vergleich mit einer Kontrollgruppe dann eben neunzig Prozent weniger schwere Verläufe.
Ja und ähm.
Ist ganz interessant. Auf Twitter hat dann irgendwie äh so eine österreichische Ärztin äh so einen kleinen Rand abgelassen ähm
dass dass das ja schon etwas sei, was sie schon seit längerem gesehen hätte, weil sie eben ähm zu den Leuten gehört, die.
Ähm die so richtig Frontline-Worker sind, ne? Also sie meinte so, ja, sie wäre halt irgendwie.
Single und hätte irgendwie auch nicht so viel Familie und da hat sie sich einfach von vornherein gemeldet und hatte einfach in den letzten Monaten extrem viel zu tun, hat also wirklich äh an der Front der Infektionsfront mit mit Leuten gearbeitet, die wirklich schwerste Verläufe haben und da hat sie halt schon
festgestellt, dass ähm sie mit diesem Asthmamittel gute Erfolge erzielen konnte und,
hat es dann irgendwie und hat er dann irgendwie auch Kontakt mit Astra Senika, was so einer der Hersteller ist von diesen Asphasprays tatsächlich. Äh nur Astra Sinnika äh ist wohl irgendwie aufgefallen, dass,
ein gesteigerter Verbrauch auf einmal war. Also sie haben halt irgendwie gesehen so warum wird denn dieses Bullisonier auf einmal so viel gekauft? Ja?
Aber sie berichtet halt eher von nicht irgendwie Interesse mit oh was ist denn da los und können wir irgendwie helfen, sondern da wurde eher gedroht, so nach dem Motto, wenn ihr hier irgendwie unser Medikament anders einsetzt, als es eigentlich gedacht ist
dann du, du, du, das wollen wir irgendwie nicht, dann kriegen wir nur Ärger von,
Na ja, jetzt gibt's auf jeden Fall diese Studie aus Oxford und es kann durchaus sein, dass das zu äh einer Änderung der Behandlung führt und ich finde neunzig Prozent ist das schon mal eine Zahl, damit kann man arbeiten.
Vielleicht werden wir das demnächst häufiger sehen und dadurch auch schwere Verläufe zurückdrängen können.
Höre zu, hoffen, ich mein das Ding ist immerhin im Landset erschienen, wenn ich das richtig sehe und scheint auch, ja.
Was für ein Reviewverfahren hat das unter Leuten durchlaufen. Okay.
Okay, ja.
Ähm also im Prinzip sagt er, sie haben halt.
Die Studie so lange laufen lassen, bis äh.
Sich sicher war, dass er sich jetzt nichts mehr ändert.
Genau bis von den Zahlen sich nicht mehr viel bewegt hat. Man sieht auch die schönen Grafiken äh und so äh dazu.
Ja und es gibt irgendwie ja eine Korrektur, also ist relativ neu, vierzehnten April äh.
Irgendwie korrigierte Version noch erschienen und ja also ähm.
Dass es auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen auch erstmal eine gute Nachricht. Mein.
Wahrscheinlich gut ist, also neunzig Prozent klingt jetzt fast wie ein Wundermittel, deswegen,
wenn man allein schon wegen der neunzig Prozent irgendwie vorsichtig sein oder hellhörig sein, aber mir ist da jetzt erstmal nichts.
Auf den ersten Blick aufgefallen, was äh irgendwie Alarmglocken äh klingeln lassen würde, so an
Studiendesign oder Durchführung oder sonst wie ein einzig die neunzig Prozent erscheinen mir irgendwie äh ja überraschend.
Hoch zu sein. So das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Und wir werden sehen.
Also es ist äh Karlabach hatte sich da auch zu äh geäußert auf Twitter meinte, das wäre halt auch, sagen wir mal, von dem, was man äh äh weiß, also Buddhisonite ist ein.
Steroid jetzt bewege ich mich wieder in so einem Bereich, von dem ich eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung habe, aber äh grundsätzlich ist es ähm einfach ein Mittel, was eine
äh
antientzündliche Wirkung hat und in dem Moment, wo man das inhaliert, geht's halt direkt in die Lunge. Und wir wissen, die Lunge ist definitiv so ein Ort, wo sich schwere Verläufe
besonders abspielen, ne? Also tief inhaliertes Virus, was wirklich weit kommt und es vor allem in die Lunge macht. Dort macht es halt Ärger. Dort führt es zu diesen
Artenproblem und dort ist äh dieser Kampf und das ist dann halt einfach eine Entzündung und äh
offensichtlich kann dieser Stoff diesen diesen Entzündungssturm der dann über die Lunge entfacht wird eindämmen.
Halt einfach äh etwas, was unter Umständen einfach gut äh passt so. Und man nimmt das dann eine Woche und dann ist äh.
Gut
dann möchte ich gerne noch auf ein Thema kommen, wo wir in unserer letzten Clubhaus äh Session nochmal drauf hingewiesen wurden. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Wir hatten ja hier auch schon ausführlich über Schnelltests gesprochen
und auch mal ausführlich diese ganzen äh Rechenmethoden ähm.
Wie das so mit Sensitivität und Spezifizität ähm zu handhaben äh ist und warum man nicht diese Worte benutzen sollte, weil man sich die ganze Zeit verquatscht, sondern vielleicht von Empfindlichkeit und Genauigkeit reden sollte.
Und überhaupt entflammt ja über diesem Land und überhaupt weltweit wahrscheinlich auch so diese ganze Zeit, diese Debatte, was bringen denn eigentlich diese Schnelltests wirklich? Und ich fand äh.
Einen Beitrag sehr hilfreich, weil er einfach nochmal in wenigen klaren Worten gesagt hat, was.
Wie man eigentlich überhaupt über Schnelltests nachdenken sollte. Wofür die gedacht sind. Das wollte ich hier an dieser Stelle nochmal wiederholen. Nämlich.
Schnelltests sind gedacht und eignen sich vor allem und ich würde sogar sagen, primär für geschlossene Gruppen.
Wo immer wieder dieselben Leute aufeinander treffen über einen längeren Zeitraum hintereinander, ja? Die in irgendeiner Form sich treffen müssen.
Was dieses Muss letztlich ausmacht, also was sozusagen dazu führt, dass auf dieses Treffen nicht verzichtet werden kann oder.
Wo man auf dieses Treffen nicht verzichten will, das lasse ich jetzt mal offen, nehmen wir einfach mal an. Es gibt das, ja? Leute im Wasserwerk, die.
Arbeiten müssen, weil wenn da keiner arbeitet, dann gibt's kein Wasser, ja, sagen wir mal, so eine Situation. Wie kann man die eben schützen mit Schnelltest? Und man kann diese Gruppen dadurch schützen, indem sich.
Alle ausnahmslos täglich testen lassen.
Das ist irgendwie eine Methode, die äh irgendwie funktioniert. Und Christian Drosten hat ja im Corona Virus Update Podcast auch nochmal.
Aktuelle Erkenntnisse hier einfließen lassen und gesagt, na ja.
Also man versteht diese Empfindlichkeit von Schnelltest jetzt immer mehr und sie haben sich das auch nochmal angeschaut und seine Kernaussage war, na ja, also Schnelltests greifen.
Nicht alle Tage, wo man infektiös ist, wirklich ab. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen dieser.
Diese Vorstellung, die im Kopf ist und die wir auch hier selber öfter schon so formuliert haben, weil das das ist, wo was aus unserer Position heraus die Nachrichtenlage war, ja, PCR findet alles.
Aber ein Schnelltest findet äh zumindest akute Infektion, weil das eben eine gewisse Virusmenge voraussetzt.
Und nun macht es einfach mehr so den Eindruck, als ob man das dann doch nochmal relativieren würde. Er hat es im Prinzip auf die Rechnung runtergebracht. Von den acht Tagen, wo man wirklich infektiös ist, nach einer Infektion.
Kann der Schnelltest vielleicht fünf abfangen. Bleiben drei über und zwar die ersten drei Tage. Vielleicht sind's auch nur zwei.
Vielleicht sind's manchmal auch, ist es auch nur einer, aber man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass auf jeden Fall Tage gibt, wo eine Infektion vorliegt.
Aber diese Schnelltests noch nicht greifen. Und wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe, war die Argumentation im Wesentlichen die diese Schnelltest oder eigentlich heißen sie ja Antigentests.
Prüfen halt auf bestimmte Antigene, auf eine bestimmte Expression, auf eine bestimmte.
Präsenz des Virus und das ist halt teilweise,
Protein teilweise sind es diese Nukleo Proteine, die halt auf dem eigentlichen Kern des Virus, auf dieser Hülle des Virus äh präsent sind.
Und versucht halt in irgendeiner Form diese Präsenz dieses Virus zu greifen. Nach einer Infektion wiederum.
Taucht ja das Virus in die Zellen ein und ist erstmal damit beschäftigt, Zellen zur Produktion.
Zu bringen, ne? Die werden ja quasi überfallen und mit vorgehaltener Pistole.
Gekörpert und gezwungen jetzt hier zu einer Virusfabrik zu werden. Und dann fangen diese Zellen an, Virus zu erzeugen.
Und in dieser allerersten Phase.
Fällt es diesen Antigentests schwer dieses Treiben zu entdecken, weil.
Etwas noch nicht passiert ist. Diese Zellen sind noch nicht gestorben.
Weil das tun sie ja dann irgendwann. Irgendwann äh verrecken sie quasi an ihrer eigenen Überforderung durch diese Dauerproduktion von Virus sterben dann einfach ab.
Andere Zellen sind mittlerweile infiziert und so setzt sich das ja immer weiter voraus. Aber diese Antigenteste gehen vor allem,
auf diese Antigene, die sich dann im Rachen erst so richtig zeigen
wenn Zellen dann auch schon gestorben sind und deswegen ist das alles ein bisschen verzögert. Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt hier keinen eklatanten Fehler gemacht, so habe ich das äh verstanden und ähm
das war so eine Erklärung warum, aber letzten Endes kann man festhalten. Schnelltests sind.
Ähm nicht für alles geeignet, auf der einen Seite und vor allem muss man sich glaube ich von diesem Gedanken trennen, dass er so ein Passport-Funktionalität hat.
Oder ein Schnelltest war jetzt irgendwie negativ.
Na dann kannst du ja jetzt nicht Infektion sein. Dann darfst du rein in diese Veranstaltung, dann darfst du rein in diesen Laden. Und ich weiß, dass es jetzt irgendwie eine Botschaft, die werdet ihr alle nicht geil finden und ich finde die auch nicht geil.
Aber es scheint so ein bisschen äh die Realität wieder zu spiegeln, dass diese Vorstellung, dass man Schnelltest als sicherer Test zum Sicher sein, so nicht.
Aussortieren von infektiösen, sagen wir mal, so, also zum einmal.
Unabhängig von ist falsch angewendet worden oder hat an sich Fehler und so weiter, sondern einfach nur die Tatsache, dass einfach ein, zwei Tage wahrscheinlich eh verpasst werden. Und das sollte zu den.
Und das genau und das mit der sozusagen Anwendung, mit den Anwendungsfehlern äh kommt halt nochmal oben drauf.
Weil was sie eben auch von PCR-Tests ja wissen ist, dass äh
Selbst bei PCA Tests, äh die manchmal negativ ausgehen, wenn der Abstrich nicht
an der richtigen Stelle äh durchgeführt worden ist oder wenn da gerade halt kein, kein Virus ist so und das trifft natürlich
umso mehr zu äh wenn halt der Test von Laien gemacht äh wird ähm,
ja unten einen Schnelltest äh auch noch ist. So, das heißt.
Praktisch können wir wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, äh dass äh ungefähr nachdem was so auch gesagt.
Hast ja größenordnungsmäßig die Hälfte, also durch durchkommt auf die eine oder andere Art. Äh wenn man halt mit,
Schnelltests äh versucht einmalig zu screenen und genauso macht es halt Machen halt auch Schnelltests,
einmal die Woche eigentlich nicht wirklich Sinn.
Auch nicht zweimal die Woche, gerade jetzt bei Schulen, wohl äh dann auch noch die Teilnahme freiwillig ist.
Also das ist nicht so äh wie ähm Schnelltest funktionieren können,
da haben wir halt auch wieder natürlich aus der Politik, so ist dann oft der Wunsch Vater des Gedankens, dass,
Dinger mehr können äh oder mehr können sollen so als sie tatsächlich in der Realität äh zu leisten in der Lage sind,
ist äh ja müsste noch ein spezielles Wort für wahrscheinlich erfinden so für diese Situation, wenn.
Die Politik im Zusammenhang mit Corona äh wieder Hoffnung auf übermäßig viel Hoffnung auf in in irgendwas steckt, was dann am Ende nur enttäuschen kann, ja.
So, also nochmal eher zusammengefasst,
Schnelltests sind sicherlich etwas, das hat seinen Platz, das kann äh äh helfen, so,
aber wenn man sie halt einsetzt für Dinge, für die sie nicht.
Geeignet sind so, dann äh macht bringt das halt auch die Schnelltests äh einfach in Verruf leider.
Auch auf Clubhaus wurden wir noch auf eine andere Methode ähm aufmerksam gemacht, wie man Schulen auch absichern kann und das ist ein etwas anderer Ansatz.
Hier kommen PCR-Tests zum,
Einsatz und zwar gepuhlte PCR-Tests. Ähm, das Ganze Projekt heißt.
Ähm wie cool wir, wofür statt das nochmal.
Äh ja, das war so ein unmögliches äh Wir irgendwie kontra Corona Virus oder so oder.
Wo ist das Corona Virus genau.
Wie Kuvier und hier wird's anders äh.
Angegangen. Und zwar sieht es so aus. Man das Ganze muss man dazu sagen, findet im Landkreis Regensburg äh.
Schulen und Universitäten dran teilen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig notiert habe.
Und hier geht's dadrum, dass zweimal die Woche,
Leute, direkt nach dem Aufstehen noch vor dem Frühstück, also so quasi als erste Maßnahme, wenn man aufgestanden ist, weil dann,
hat man vom vom Schlafen sozusagen sein Rachen auch noch nicht besonders gut durchgespült. Gurgelt und zwar einfach nur mit Trinkwasser. Also man geht ins Bad.
Macht sich ein Glas Wasser voll, nimmt einen Schluck, gurgelt damit.
Und spuckt das gegoogelte einfach in zwei Probenbehälter rein. Fertig.
Das gibt man dann ab.
Eine Probe wird zurückgelegt, die andere Probe wird dann mit anderen Proben in so einem Pool, PCR verfahren, zusammengekippt und gemeinsam getestet, also Pooling.
Relativ klar heißt einfach nur, man kombiniert eben mehrere Proben von verschiedenen Leuten in einem macht eine PCA drauf, dadurch wird es halt billiger, weil.
Wenn man zehn zusammenkippt, dann zahlt man nur einen PCR-Test für zehn Leute und wenn nur eine Person davon.
Positiv war, ist halt im Idealfall der ganze Test positiv und dann kann man sehen, aha, okay, das war jetzt hier diese zusammengekippte Probe, jetzt
proben wir die Zehen, die da einzeln reingegangen sind, nochmal separat, um rauszufinden, wer jetzt hier positiv ist.
Ja, Vorteil.
Dadurch, dass es PCR ist, natürlich sehr viel frühere Erkennung. Hier mag dann zweimal die Woche durchaus greifen.
Ja, also es ist zweimal die Woche PCR, hat äh in etwa dieselbe Wirkung wie täglich Schnelltest.
Aber du hast halt eine höhere Sensitivität und dadurch, dass es halt auch nur ein Gurgeln mit Trinkwasser und Ausspucken ist morgens.
Ist es auch null invasiv.
Kein Stäbchen, was sie da irgendwo reinschieben muss und wo du dir bei jedem Mal an der Wand kratzen und man muss schon niesen oder findest irgendwie äh einfach nur eklig, unangenehm oder es tut vielleicht auch weh. Ja, was immer dazu führen kann, dass dann Proben dann vielleicht
ein bisschen nachlässiger genommen werden oder vielleicht auch gar nicht so richtig ja, das entfällt hier alles, weil Google kann, glaube ich, am Ende jeder.
Und ähm ja, das ist so deren Ansatz und äh wer vielleicht noch nach tauglichen Lösungen sucht, um
Schulen zumindest auf eine Art und Weise abzusichern, die diesen ganzen Schnelltestwahnsinn äh nicht wählen, könnte sich auf
dieses Projekt stürzen.
Ja allerding.
Auf Weekare Punkt DE Strich Care Punkt DE.
Allerdings habe ich mir jetzt gerade mal die Zahlen vom Landkreis Regensburg äh äh hochgeholt und.
Ähm ja ähm die Zahlen sehen nicht,
gut aus, also vor allem für Schulen nicht dort sind halt ist halt die Inzidenz an Schulen jetzt
in der letzten Woche von zweihundert auf zweihundertachtzig gestiegen. Also was auch immer die da an Schulen machen. Ich meine das muss jetzt nicht äh äh an diesem Projekt,
liegen oder so.
Aber ich will nur sagen, entweder äh sind halt in dieses Projekt nicht hinreichend äh genug Teilnehmer ein äh bezogen äh auf jeden Fall äh ja was immer
gemacht wird in äh Regensburg, äh die.
Der Corona Virus in der Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn lässt sich davon überhaupt nicht beeindrucken, sondern äh ja im Gegenteil,
Das explodiert da allerdings äh sind,
Kitas im Vergleich äh jetzt äh noch,
relativ weit unten, also sie sind gerade mal bei einer Institanz von hundertzehn und also was sie da auch immer mit den Kitas machen äh so, das scheint zumindest einen.
Gewissen Effekt zu haben.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht die Methode, die da flächendeckend eingesetzt wird, sondern das ist eine Studie, die da gemacht wird.
Also das ist sozusagen der Versuch eine Alternative zu finden und wenn wir jetzt hohe Zahlen haben, dann könnt ihr das auch eher ein Argument dafür sein, dass man mal was anderes ausprobiert. Ähm das Ganze hat wohl irgendwie im Februar äh angefangen, ist also auch noch relativ,
neu und ähm könnte aber auf jeden Fall interessant sein.
Ja und so andere Tests über die wir auch schon mal gesprochen haben sind ja Abwassertests. Ja hm,
da ist mir jetzt gerade nochmal ähm reingespült worden, Ergebnisse aus der
da wird es nämlich im Kanton Zürich tatsächlich gemacht, also was wird gemacht? Man geht ins Klärwerk
und nimmt halt einfach die Abflüsse der Stadt.
Und macht dort seine PCA Tests auf dem Abwasser und das konnte eigentlich auch schon mehrfach gezeigt werden, dass das an sich ganz gut funktioniert.
So meinen manche, andere meinen was anderes und ähm
ich blicke hier nur gerade auf die Grafik, wie sich das in Zürich so äh verhält, also was sagen die Abwassertests und was was sagen die tatsächlichen ähm Institenzen der Verlauf durch die normalen PCR-Tests und
die sind schon relativ nah beieinander
Da wurde dann im Verlauf auch nochmal das Anti-Gen geändert, auf das getestet wurde, aber zumindest das, womit man das jetzt derzeit macht,
doch den Institutionsverlauf schon sehr gut nach. Was will ich damit sagen.
Ich will damit sagen, ich wundere mich, dass es in Deutschland immer noch so wenig zum Einsatz kommt. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig sicher,
wo es vielleicht doch in Deutschland zum Einsatz kommt, aber ähm ich hatte hier so einen Bericht gefunden vom von der deutschen Welle.
Und da wird eigentlich im Wesentlichen ähm davon berichtet, dass die deutschen Behörden hier,
sehr skeptisch sind und das äh eher nicht unterstützen und nicht äh machen, obwohl es zum Beispiel in der TU Darmstadt da sehr wertvolle Arbeiten äh zugibt.
Ja, also TU Darmstadt meint, man könnte äh zehn Fälle auf hunderttausend Einwohner genau nachmessen. Und das ist natürlich ähm.
Schon interessante äh Geschichte. Man könnte Varianten nachweisen ähm und ähm.
Das kommt in der Schweiz zum Einsatz, das kommt in Holland, zur Einsatz kommt in USA und in Frankreich, zum Einsatz, aber in Deutschland scheint auch das wie keine Option zu sein.
Warum auch immer.
Scheiße stinkt und ja irgendwie und man möchte es glaube ich auch nicht so genau wissen.
Den Eindruck habe ich eigentlich mittlerweile auch so. Also man, oh Mann, oh Mann.
Pavel, damit sind wir eigentlich so ein bisschen am Ende angekommen dieser Sendung. Ich wollte nochmal ein.
Ein Tweet zitieren von einem Twitter-Account, den ich irgendwie immer wieder sehr äh gerne lese in dieser Zeit. Vom bissigen Mäuschen hatte ich hier schon mal.
Äh und zwar wendet sich das so ein bisschen auch so an die Gesellschaft und beziehungsweise Jammerei, die man irgendwie überall sieht.
Ich lese das mal vor. Es muss endlich Schluss sein mit der Panikmache. Es kann nicht sein, dass bei jedem Vorschlag einer Maßnahme,
schon das Ende der freien Gesellschaft herbeigejammert wird. Das ist peinlich, wenn jeder Widerspruch und jede Korrektur von Falschbehauptung zum Tod der Meinungsfreiheit stilisiert wird.
Zufeige ist seine eigenen Befindlichkeiten zu formulieren, darf sich nicht hinter einem vermeintlichen Willen des Volks oder der Bürger verstecken. Ja, es werden Menschen auch durch,
Maßnahmen krank, manche werden sterben und ihre Jobs verlieren. Es sind harte Zeiten für uns alle, aber wir glauben daran, dass es möglich ist, zum Wohl aller Corona und andere Probleme zu überwinden. Und dass die Zeit danach einfach klasse wird.
Ihr habt Angst, dass eure Welt schon beim kleinsten Versuch dazu auf Dauer zusammenbricht. Wenn eure Welt.
Euer soziales Umfeld, wenn eure Ideale so fragil sind, dass jede Berührung durch andere, egal wie berechtigt sie Zerbrechen droht, dann müsst ihr
euch damit zu Hause hinter dem Sofa verstecken. Eure Freiheit ist,
schwacher auf der Brust als irgendein Patient auf der Intensivstation. Wenn ihr die Triage nicht fürchtet, dann müsst ihr jetzt loslassen. Eure Freiheit ist nicht stark genug, um in der echten Welt lebensfähig zu sein. Sie darf ja nicht mal berührt werden.
Unsere ist stark genug, um dafür zu kämpfen, selbst wenn es langen Atem braucht. Hört auf zu jammern, habt den Mut, eure Ideale auch in schweren Zeiten zu leben, anstatt nur äh um sie herum zu flennen.
Ihr habt nicht nur Angst und macht Panik, ihr seid auch noch zur Feige, euch dem einzustellen, denn dann versteckt euch halt und lasst uns machen. Ja, die Welt wird danach nicht die gleiche sein, aber dem stellen wir uns und wir lassen euch äh auch wieder rein,
wenn ihr euch traut. Aber vielleicht hängt ihr dann auch lieber weiter an einer verklärten Vergangenheit wie ein verschreckter Säugling am Beinkleid eines Eltern,
Und wenn ihr bei dem Satz wiedergezuckt habt, gebt wenigstens zu, wie viel Schiss ihr habt und verkauft uns das nicht als Stärke, fordert nicht von uns, den Mut, eure fragile Welt zu erhalten
Wir setzen unseren Mut für,
unsere Welt ein, wir haben den Mut mit zitternden Händen im Angesicht des Todes an unserer Welt zu bauen und mit dem Blick über unsere eigenen Befindlichkeiten hinaus.
Deshalb hört mit der Panikmache auf, macht mit oder haltet die Klappe.
Ja, sehr schön, ja.
Ist es halt auch so diese dieser Jammerei auch so viel Raum zu geben in der Politik und und davor davon zu laufen. Ich habe heute grad wieder irgendwie so ein Video gesehen von irgendwelchen.
Leute, keine Ahnung, Querdenker, was auch immer, halt diese ganzen Telegramm, inspirierten Menschen, die dann irgendwie.
Hunderte von Kilometern durch die Republik gefahren sind, um mal wieder den Sturm auf den Reichstag äh zu feiern und dann irgendwie festzustellen, dass da irgendwie
fünf verspringte Typen irgendwie auf diesem Reichstagsrasen rumlaufen und dazu noch irgendwie eine Hundertschaftpolizei
und beschweren sich dann so jämmerlich so, ja wo sind denn alle, wo ist denn hier die Revolution? Ich habe doch die Revolution, habe ich doch gelesen, dass im Internet jetzt das jetzt hier irgendwie Revolution ist und und unsere Freiheit und überhaupt und
Ja ihr seid einfach die Minderheit.
Ihr seid einfach ein, ein, ein, ein Grüppchen von Leuten, die zwar sehr laut sind und sehr gehässig und die bereit sind, auf jeden, der irgendwie versucht.
Wirklich durch viel Arbeit diese Krise zu überwinden, rumzuhacken.
Ihr seid einfach Jammerloppen und es ist einfach ihr müsst einfach mal zurücktreten. Es führt einfach zu zu gar nichts und mich nervt das auch tierisch.
Nur langweilig und schlecht.
Also mich erinnerte das äh sagen an den Begriff irgendwie Kartelle der Angst. Ähm,
der schon etwas älter ist ähm
und irgendwie von dem Soziologen glaube ich geprägt wurde oder sogar Ernie, ah ja Ralf Dahndorf hat sogar das Kartell der Angst geschrieben, sehe ich gerade. Also es ist ein
sondern immer wieder gern genommener Begriff und was was sich dahinter verbirgt,
ist im Wesentlichen ja eine äh das ist halt eine Gruppe von Leuten gibt.
Die Angst vor Veränderung hat ähm so und sich deswegen der Änderung äh widersetzt gemeinsam und sich gegen Änderungen stemmt,
ja kann man wahrscheinlich auch beim Klima so beobachten und aber generell bei anderen Dingen, also überhaupt das Internet, der ganze Kampf ums Urheberrecht und und so weiter.
Rund äh ja oder auch eigentlich teilweise unsere Automobilhersteller mittlerweile, obwohl die eigentlich ja zu den innovativsten äh oder noch, ich sage mal, am am bestvernetzten
äh Wirtschaftsstrukturen äh mit viel Innovation, viel Forschungsausgaben und so gehören aber mittlerweile ja hat man auch da das Gefühl
dass sie einfach auch und das macht die Kartelle der Angst auch aus, dass sie eben so viel Macht haben
sie ja Gesetzgebung und Handeln der Regierung,
beeinflussen und gerne einen regulativen Rahmen herstellen, der ihnen zugute kommt und äh ja und jetzt haben wir halt vielleicht das neue Kapitel so
Pandimie trifft auf deutsche Kartelle der Angst. So das ist glaube ich, dass,
wonach das, wonach das Klangplus dann ähm ja äh dann halt die ganz, ganz vielen, die.
Schlecht informiert sind. So kann man das glaube ich auch sagen.
Ja, wir hoffen, dass wir äh dafür sorgen, dass ihr besser informiert seid und dass ihr euch nicht in die Kartelle der Angst einreiht, aber äh das wissen wir eigentlich schon.
Das dem so ist. Wir machen auf jeden Fall unsere Clubhausrunde, diesmal am kommenden Montag schon.
Tag früher als sonst aus Gründen um einundzwanzig Uhr. Wenn ihr dabei sein könnt und wollt, dann,
Macht das, ansonsten gibt's Kroner Wickli, nächsten Freitag wird's wieder aufgenommen und äh.
Klingt euch gerne wieder ein. Wir bedanken uns für eure Unterstützung und äh die Kommentare und all die sonstigen Hinweise, die wir aus allen Richtungen bekommen und sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss, macht's gut, bleibt gesund.